the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
hey everybody what's going on lighting
looks nice I think I didn't write this
right
looks like
a little too bright let me see oh I
don't know
I don't know but hey how's everybody
doing this should actually be a pretty
fun show I've been wanting to do this
one for a while
um if you've been around here for a long
time we actually did do a mysteries of
Rock and Roll Show way back on episode
and I had to go and look up because I
didn't remember like what we had done on
that one we did
um Robert Johnson selling his soul to
the devil uh we did the whole Dark Side
of the Moon Wizard of Oz thing uh we
talked about the deaths of Brian Jones
and Bobby Fuller we talked about Orion
the Elvis Orion thing uh we did talk
about the 27 club because John goris
just mentioned that and I also wrote
down Sammy Hagar getting abducted by
aliens and I was like wow I don't
remember it I don't remember that but I
guess we did actually maybe talk about
it on the show
I guess so but like I said I don't
remember any so we talked about that on
apparently on the last show uh John
goris is talking about the 27 Club yeah
and actually two of the people we're
talking about tonight obviously Jim
Morrison and Jimi Hendrix are members of
the 27 Club although I was looking
something up and they were just kind of
like well statistically yeah it does
seem weird that like a lot of rock stars
um seem to die at that age but it's not
not statistically significant it's just
like a coincidence because they said
there's also a cluster of them around
like some other ages too but nobody
talks about that
so but it is kind of weird that like
that is there is a bunch of them around
that now Camp guy said uh yeah Kurt
Cobain and Courtney Love I actually kind
of considered doing that one but then I
was like well I don't really know if
there's any mystery there I know that
there's this whole thing that um you
know that people think that Courtney
Love killed him and [__] like that but I
don't believe that and I don't think
there's really any evidence to support
that not that I know a huge amount about
it but I mean that seemed like a pretty
straight up
suicide to me so I don't know maybe if
we do like a volume three like I'll talk
about it like or at least I'll talk
about the controversy because the thing
about it is that
on this show like I said I wanted to
talk about uh Jimi Hendrix and Jim
Morrison not because anybody well I'm
not gonna say not because anybody
thinks they were murdered because some
people think that uh the Jimi Hendrix in
particular was murdered
um but I think that it's more a case of
people not like no not knowing if they
committed suicide or if it was an
accident or I think even in Jim
Morrison's case some people think he
like faked his death or I don't know
[__] like that so yeah no obviously
that's not what it is the Jim Morrison
Well no I know what it is I know what it
is we're gonna get into it I'm just
saying that that was another thing that
people say about it it's not you know
what I mean because I already
investigated that and the Jim Morrison
rumor I believe is true
well it doesn't sound all that
far-fetched to me to be honest people
that knew him said that he didn't die in
that bathtub right okay but yeah I mean
we'll get into that like that I think
that's the third one where that we're
talking about
um but yeah
so let me see I was so they're talking
about
um Camp guy said I didn't know that
Robert Plant had a child that died I
didn't actually know that either yeah
Sebastian said um an alleged curse from
uh it's baleskin house isn't it that you
know did we did a show about that didn't
we that was uh the Aleister Crowley kind
of [__] yeah it wasn't much of a house
either that Jimmy Page was kind of
crappy it does look kind of crappy yeah
or weren't they trying to like because
like we did a show about it a while back
like with all the weird like occult [__]
that was going on there and everything
and they were talking about restoring it
and I don't know I haven't heard
anything since then like how that's been
going early didn't have much money
mm-hmm when he was young
not much money in there yeah a lot of
notoriety but he just would have been
nowadays just been a goth kid
yeah just a very [__] creepy and [__]
he was kind of ahead of his time but
weird yeah I suppose so I suppose so
probably a male prostitute too from
whatever
oh I never heard that did we even talk
about that because we did a show about
Alistair Crowley too we I think didn't
we do two separate houses two separate
shows we did one about Alistair Crowley
and one about uh yeah I remember reading
something from a witness that knew him
when he was young and said that he would
do anything for money it is in his 20s
partying constantly and evidently would
like
he was that kind of a guy well you know
it's not like I mean a lot of people
yeah
yeah so it probably wasn't that big a
deal yeah yeah John Gore said didn't uh
Katy Perry by I forget either Aleister
Crowley's place or the Tate labianca
house I
love Bianca house but I could be totally
wrong about that
I only I didn't even remember it until
you mentioned it
yeah I'm not really sure why you'd wanna
superstitious or anything like that it
would be kind of like I think the only
pain in the ass about buying a house
where people got murdered was just
because you'd have like all these True
Crime lookie-los like coming through
there taking pictures of your house and
that would be kind of annoying
um you know or people knocking the door
being like hey can we come inside and
look at it I'm not worried about it
being like cursed or haunted or nothing
like that but I would worry about like
people coming by they're looking at it
should be creepy
I yeah I guess it would be
yeah but I mean if it was cheap enough
okay we get off on the show wanted to
mention something uh I was looking
through some old comments because I
don't see the comments as they come up
on on the videos but I have to go back
and I'll check them every month or so
go back and look at comments over the
past month and I noticed that there was
a comment by Danny rolling Ghostface
saying he can no longer comment in the
live chat
and we can't figure out why nobody's
blocked in the live chat yeah yeah I
think he thought that one of us had
blocked him but I didn't block him I
have it there's nobody blocked on this
show he's blocked I went and looked at
the account and no one right and I don't
and I have controls to silence people
or put them in timeout and stuff I think
I can't kick them out
I don't have any list anywhere to see
anybody who's blocked I don't know if
he's accidentally blocked maybe somebody
can tell me
how this might work I do have moderator
power is on this [__] but I don't see
moderator yeah but I don't seem to have
any I can only hide a user
um or put a user and time out or remove
a comment
so I can't block anybody
and honestly like I'm not even I use um
OBS so I have like a live chat window
but I can't do [__] all from this window
so I can't block anybody like in the
live chat either and like I said I was
like well maybe it happened accidentally
like maybe somebody blocked him but I
went back into the 13 o'clock account
and there are zero block numbers nobody
is blocked so I'm not really entirely
sure like why he can't comment and watch
that anymore it's got to be yeah I don't
know if it was that or if it was because
I would think like if one of the other
moderators had kicked him out for some
reason which I don't know why they would
but he'd be on the block list well no
moderator doesn't have the ability to
ban anybody right just kick him out like
or you have or make them invisible so
I'm not really sure like how that
happened I don't know if it's some like
some kind of glitch or anything but
we're not mad at you I swear to God like
we didn't do anything I didn't do
anything and I didn't even like realize
until we were looking back at some of
the old comments and I was just like oh
[__] I didn't
I was like I can't I can't block anybody
in OBS because I don't have there it
looks like there's controls but there's
not you can't do it you can't do
anything like in the chat window I don't
know what the issue is it's not us yeah
so I don't know either uh Tammy said
yeah I've been wondering where Danny's
been yeah that's the thing it's just
like when I thought about it I was like
damn what the [__] what the [__] and it
was like several episodes back what um
it was a couple months ago it was a
couple months ago I can't remember what
the topic was a couple months back but
um but yeah I just said I didn't see it
yeah otherwise I would have checked
before now so like I said
yeah nobody I swear to God it was like
not a single person is blocked on this
channel nobody at all I went through my
Google AdSense thing and everything and
looked at everything
um yeah yeah
um murder Hornet said uh I know why it
has a new policy one of my Mexico videos
I was cussing and someone said my
comments were off to keep it safe for
miners YouTube does it automatically oh
okay maybe that's what it is maybe
that's what it was yeah because like I
said I didn't block you and Tom didn't
block you
so nobody blocked you yeah I got you
we're not mad yeah that's that kind of
makes sense and actually I got a message
earlier today from
um from um DJ maniac and he was like how
many you guys videos are to monetized
and I was like probably I don't know if
it's half but it's probably like 40 or
something like that well just because
topics yeah usually the topics anything
that's true crime I mean unless you
really I mean there's a lot of True
Crime videos that aren't demonetized but
they really have to like tiptoe around
and like use euphemisms and [__] like
that which I'm just not good at doing
that and I honestly and I can't really
talk without swearing so we've been
sorry
basically I just can't the show
basically
um
um [__] survives off of patrons
off of patreon yeah and occasional super
chats I mean we I do get some ad Revenue
but not much yeah because we do have a
lot of videos up and there are actually
a lot of them that are so much
but AdSense doesn't add up too much or
maybe 100 bucks a month maybe I think
last month it was 154. 154 okay
and like I said a lot of them are
I'm still waiting to see if they're
gonna re-instate
that Meg 2 review that they took down
because of copyright by Ella oh is this
supposed to be 10 days yeah it's
supposed to be 10 days it should be 10
days right well I don't know I don't
remember okay it's probably about that
okay but we'll see I don't imagine that
they wouldn't put that back up because
it's like what are they gonna do sue me
yeah oh I forgot to mention it what the
show might find it's interesting
remember how um
acidic on on that fuel Fireball that I
have I kept adjusting the damn clutch of
a cable it's kept getting loose on me
as I adjusted it like four times at the
basket
and it still would go get loose it'd
have about a [__] more than a quarter
inch of free play in the line
so I came in today and I said I'm gonna
adjust it at the clutch basket itself
did it test drove it and as I was going
down the street I [__] dropped it
into gear really hard and the damn
clutch lever went flying off that came
out of the perch and was [__]
dangling the the and I was in gear
couldn't get it out of gear in first
gear I actually I was able to get it
down into first gear and then I got it
up in the garage and um
killed it and uh got off of it and
looked in there took it apart and looked
in there
[__] the clutch throw out bearings
are gone it's only only 20 bucks I
ordered them
but they just
when I reached in when I [__] took
the thing out
just a whole bunch of ball bearings fell
out
she's everywhere there was just powdered
metal in there
where it was just the ball bearings just
[__] disintegrated I was lucky that
that happened here
not when I was out
yep that would have sucked yeah so I
gotta put a new bearing in there
it's no big deal though
just uh but that could have been pretty
catastrophic
because you'd have been stuck in gear no
way to go to going to neutral no way to
stop at a stoplight yikes yeah can't
pull the clutch out so you don't tell me
[__] and then you can't find neutral you
just had to kill the bike don't tell me
well you got a kill switch
I know but on the controls
but you I've just been out of bed stuck
wherever I get I'm going what the [__]
you know in the middle of summer yeah
you can't turn the bike on because you
can't go into neutral right yeah
Michael cernicke says Jim Morrison died
and became Rush Limbaugh
hahaha
that's a good one he did get fat
um he wasn't that fat
yeah but he wasn't what he well no but I
mean he was a bad drunk yeah
the might Bowser says the next two guys
she was a [__] heroin addict too um
you know what though uh I don't know
that might be everyone that knew I can't
say that well no I mean everybody that
knew him like at least from all the
documentaries that I watched
um most of them said he wasn't real big
on heroin now his girlfriend was a
heroin addicts Pamela corsan
um and he apparently was always trying
to get her off it because he didn't like
her he did other drugs he wasn't like
that but um
yeah I don't I don't know but I'm just
saying that um more selling it than
anything else and that's that's the
story that I heard from people that knew
him from that club
he was at a bar that used to hang out
with we're getting ahead of ourselves
yeah because that's like two like that's
like three stories in uh yeah the mate
Bowser says the meg2 got struck what you
guys just talked about the movie yeah
that's what I said
yeah I didn't show the trailer I didn't
show anything all we did was talk about
the movie I said I didn't I didn't show
any stills from the movie nothing and we
gave it a good review yeah so I just
thought it was weird like well I've
heard like I said that Warner Brothers
is a little overzealous yeah uh with
their copyright thing although I you
know I made the point when I contested
it I was like you know there's like a
whole bunch of other reviews of it that
actually did use the trailer and did use
stills from it and [__] like that and
they're still there and gave it a bad
review yeah and didn't really like it
all that much so it's like what's your
[__] problem you know what I mean I
wasn't that [__] I was a little bit
[__] I liked it better than the first
one I'll admit I was a little bit [__]
but I was kind of trying to you know
yeah
I want to buy that [__] in a three
movie set
just because it's crazy crazy and dumb
Michael said Jim's dad was a powerful
Admiral and helped fake his death look
it up yeah I mean the thing about it
yeah his dad was really not um he was a
military guy and so Jim Morrison like
moved around a lot when he was a kid
um and his dad did really really did not
get the rock star thing
um even saying to Jim at some point that
he's just like you shouldn't do it
because you don't have any talent in
that regard and I was just like okay
nice Dad that's a lot what do you know
that well yeah exactly he grew up in
another era where they [__] you know
yeah he didn't get it yeah
but that's why I was watching I was
watching like a um Dr Grande was doing
like a psychological evaluation like of
Jim Morrison and he was talking about
he's like you know the dad it's like he
did obviously he seemed to love his son
but he just didn't
understand like it you know it was like
a generational difference which like I
said was a lot more extreme back then
and because his dad was so strict and so
um you know of a different generation of
a difference it's like greatest
Generation World War II right he did
they didn't get rock and roll at all no
that wasn't their thing no not at all
and you know it's just kind of like I
remember kind of growing up in that era
where they thought well you couldn't
make any money with anything artistic
you know they were just like oh don't
you want to go into something like
accounting or something where you're
gonna like make some money you know what
I mean like they didn't think that you
could make any money with anything if
they didn't like it then they think they
didn't think it would sell but they
didn't like anything right that's what I
mean it's like what the [__] do you guys
know yeah [__] man nowadays there's like
[__] 20 year old guys making millions
of dollars just playing video games
or whatever this has been like a [__]
constant for 2 000 years or [__]
probably could go because I could you
could trace it back to Rome maybe
another thousand years before Greece
don't listen to your dad or your parents
just do what you want man yeah let's
talk about some things but not about
what's cool what to wear or what to
listen to and how to make money because
especially in another ever-changing
world that we're talking about the 20th
century in the 21st century [__] changed
so fast your parents knowledge was
obsolete by the time you got out of high
school
High School couldn't teach anything
because they were teaching you something
that was old old anyway and it didn't
apply when you got out you couldn't
really get a job there they that they
teach you so it's just then you had to
go to university and I don't really
think anybody worked in their field it
was just a ticket into a club
so uh no [__]
when I was growing up my parents were
like I don't [__] waste your time
playing those goddamn video games you
know that's nothing
yeah a little they know those guys are
making more than [__] pro football
players
some of them yeah yeah which is crazy to
think about but yeah it's absolutely
true yeah they're girls on social media
they have no other skills other than
that they're pretty making [__] six
figures yeah there's not a lot of them
but there's there's enough of them
and uh making more than a student than a
Hollywood actress
you know because everything's targeted
now and specialized
I remember back in the day you were just
praying you know the the only the only
beautiful women you receive would be in
movies maybe television maybe a magazine
or something
but it was always being filtered through
people selecting these women to show you
you know like you'd see a movie actress
oh man she's cute but you didn't see the
millions of other women that are just in
their bedroom
in their house they were even cuter well
now they got Instagram models yeah so
there is she's just taking pictures of
herself she can take badasses beautiful
ladies everywhere yeah and they're not
fitting any stereotype you know all
different shapes you know so you can
just go after the ones you can get
pictures of the ones you like you can
choose what your favorite one is that
was I'm dreamed of when we were kids
that's the I think that's kind of the
main thing that I dig about yeah it's
like everything is just so in some ways
it's like so it's harder to break
through but in a lot of ways it's
everything is a lot more curated to your
own taste you can find exactly what you
like a living you can make a living yeah
it's like most people aren't getting
super rich off the [__] but yeah people
can make a living doing that kind of
stuff just kind of targeting a specific
market like yeah and you're getting
their own little fans as long as you're
worked as long as you're working it as a
job like those girls girls that are
successful they work put in 40 hours a
week taking photos and on Twitter and
running social yeah it's a job like any
other job I mean it's still work and
when I was in high school they never
could have given us an education on how
to set up a Twitter account and make
[__] six figures as an Instagram
model they didn't even dream of that job
that wasn't a job yeah it's a job now
yeah
I think some people still think of it as
not as one but it absolutely is it's a
job it's a lot of work it's a job it's
in the entertainment industry it's a lot
of work it's just that Hollywood doesn't
control the entertainment anymore
internet does
the platforms do
Michael says the Bobby Fuller death was
a weird one yeah we I didn't want to
like redo that one because we did that
one on the last one but that might be
something where we want to revisit like
at some point because that was pretty
[__] weird John Gore said most Gamers
athletes and performers don't make it
for every Brad Pitt there's 40 000 guys
trying to beat him maybe a thousand in
Earnest yeah that's true and I but I
kind of feel like that's true of a lot
of fields though yeah but you thought
you could if those dudes stick to it and
there's anything to them they'll find a
niche even if that dude's just up on
stream mate beating it in front of
[__] dudes and the thing is that he
might not make it in the sense that he's
like rich but he's like making a living
he's making a living like it might not
be like a real fancy living but you know
he's paying his wrench right and I mean
maybe it wasn't what he expected
yeah but well nothing ever I think
people's I think people I think most
people's expectations of making money
through social media are pretty
realistic actually most of them anybody
over the age of [__] 25
yeah and I think most people are just
trying to I mean yeah I really like
younger people are probably be like oh I
want to be a millionaire or whatever but
I think like once you get a little bit
older you're kind of like well I just
want to make a living at this yeah you
know what I mean which is really all you
can ask for look these girls trying to
make a living on only fans yeah they
gotta [__] work that as a job a
full-time job and
um
if you're working as a full-time job and
you look pretty good and you know how to
work that and tie it in with
Twitter or Twitter and other social
medias yeah you might make 30 40 50 000
a year you can survive on that
you're not gonna make [__] a million
yeah they got a sum that could will but
that's a top top well one percent like I
said true of anything yeah that's true
of anything
uh Isabella Mars says the Richie Edwards
situation is the saddest for me that is
very sad uh is yeah we're going to talk
about that one that'll be like the last
one because I'm doing them in
chronological order because why not
so I guess we'll get into this because
there are actually five stories they're
not all super long so it's not like I'm
gonna be here all night but you know
what I mean uh hi everybody
uh hi Mandy
um
oh Mr idiot said the Tate house no
longer exists it was demolished a few
years ago
oh yeah
I forgot about that yeah Nine Inch Nails
album the downward spiral was completely
recorded in the tatehouse yeah I forgot
about that too
I had I had totally forgotten I had
totally spaced down on the idea that
house wasn't there anymore
so I guess Katy Perry didn't uh
didn't buy the tail up yeah I was
because it's not there anymore
so maybe it was the I'm pretty sure that
that Aleister Crowley house is still
there though
but like I said it was a couple years
ago we did a show about that all right
so the first one I want to talk about
is
the death of Sam Cooke
now I kind of feel like anybody that
knows
um a lot about music history will know
who Sam Cook is but in case you don't
um he is actually a legendary
soul singer referred to as the king of
Soul one of the most influential Soul
artists of all time
um he actually started out as a gospel
singer
because his dad was a minister and he
was in a gospel band called The Soul
stirs and they got signed to a label uh
in the 50s and he actually
um then went solo in 1957 and had uh he
was really really famous had like a lot
of really
um big hit songs you send me Change Is
Gonna Come uh chain gang
uh you know songs like that so super
super famous
another thing that he did too
um he wrote all his own music which was
slightly unusual for the time
and also in 1964 he founded his own
record label and his own Publishing
Company
um he was actually one of the first
black artists to establish his own
Publishing Company because retaining the
rights to his own music was very very
important to him so that was another way
that he was kind of like a pioneer
now uh he was also very up in the uh you
know kind of a big figure in the Civil
Rights Movement he was friends with
Malcolm X and uh Muhammad Ali and all of
that so that kind of thing maybe
it's not so much because because some
people think that he was
okay some people think that he was
murdered he was murdered but
um
it's kind of a complicated story but
some people think he was murdered like
deliberately rather than like
justifiably murderers you know what I
mean he was assassinated yeah well not
okay but yeah we'll get into it I'll get
into that a little bit but some people
have said that just like oh maybe it was
because he was you know in the Civil
Rights Movement like that he got killed
because of that um and they kind of
covered it up to make it look like this
justifiable homicide situation but um
but yeah but but I don't know about that
I think it's kind of more likely I don't
know I think I kind of buy the official
um just you know spoiler alert I think I
kind of buy the official uh you know
series of events but if he actually was
murdered by anybody
um it was probably the guy that stood to
gain the most from his death which was
probably his manager it was kind of a
Shifty individual which we'll get into a
little bit
but so this is what happened
1964 it was December 11th
now Sam Cook was actually shot in the
chest at the Hacienda motel in South
Central Los Angeles
now what ended up happening so there
were two separate calls of a shooting
and a kidnapping
um and the cops came and he had had one
gunshot wound to the chest uh which had
pierced his heart
now so when they start doing the
investigation the manager of the
Hacienda Motel whose name is Bertha
Franklin she admitted I shot him in
self-defense she actually shot three
times but she missed him two times and
the third but the third one
went into his chest
now this was corroborated by the owner
of the motel his name was Evelyn Carr
she said she had been on the phone with
Bertha Franklin at the time the incident
happened and she said that she heard Sam
Cook coming into the office and the
whole fight and the gunshots and
everything like that
so this is what she said happen
she says
um Bertha says that Sam Cook had checked
into the ho the motel earlier that
evening
and then after a little while he had
come running to the door of the office
like banging on the door of the motel
office asking where's the girl
now he was supposedly asking about this
woman named Elisa Boyer and she was a
girl uh you know a young woman that had
accompanied him to the motel earlier in
the evening
she had also separately called the
police from a telephone booth near the
motel before the owner of the motel also
called the police so there were like
several calls
so Bertha said at that point she hears
him bang at the door saying where's the
girl and Bertha says there's nobody in
here except me
but apparently Sam Cooke was did not
believe this and was like enraged so he
forced his way into the motel office
she said that he was completely naked
except for a sport jacket and one shoe
okay
just one shoe yeah for whatever reason
well there was a reason but um I don't
know about the one shoe but I do know
about the about the sport jacket so
apparently he grabs her and says where
is that girl like where's that girl
Elisa who was talking about
and according to Bertha she started
grappling with him the two of them fell
on the floor and then she kind of got
away from him she got up and ran to get
her gun
and then she started shooting at him
because she thought he was gonna kill
her
so like I said she missed twice but um
one of the shots got him in the heart
now according to her he actually said in
a very surprised voice lady you shot me
which is actually if you look it up that
is actually a documentary about Sam Cook
it's called lady you shot me it came out
in 2017. I actually watched it earlier
this week
um but says even after he was shot he
still kind of kept coming at her so she
said that she hit him in the head with a
broomstick and then he fell on the floor
and died I just know this guy no no yeah
yeah he I mean he was famous like she
knew who he was but he had just like
checked into the motel she was just the
motel manager yeah he just came to the
motel allegedly he just came like asking
where that girl went he was nude
yeah except for that thing is so you
must have got rolled or something well
this is disoriented well this is what
happened yeah so Elisa who was the girl
that had come with him to the motel
earlier
she told the cops that she had met Sam
Cook at a nightclub earlier that night
and said they had hung out and they left
the nightclub together
um but he was real drunk and she said
that she asked him to take her home but
he wouldn't he took it to the hotel so
he actually drove her uh to this Motel
yeah and Elisa said that this Motel it's
like the way that he walked around it he
it seemed like he had been there before
um
so she's like he checked into one of the
rooms she puts her in one of the rooms
she alleges that Sam Cook
um like physically pushed her onto the
bed and then tore her clothes off and
she was afraid that he was going to rape
her
now she asked if she could go use the
bathroom he said she could she went in
there and she tried to climb out of the
window but apparently the window would
not open
like it was painted shut or something
like that
so then she comes back to the main room
and she says that Sam Cooke continues to
like assault her or whatever and then he
went in to use the bathroom because like
I said he was very inebriated and then
she picked up her clothes and also
apparently got some of his clothes too
in the pile which is why he didn't have
any in the room and she got the [__] out
of there
now she actually went to the motel
office first and banged on the door but
it took too long like for the manager to
come the door and she was afraid that
Sam Cooke was running after her so she
said [__] this and she just
um like skid-addled she just like ran
out of there she put her clothes back on
stuck Sam's clothes somewhere like out
in the parking lot or whatever and then
went to a telephone booth and called the
police
now every bit okay so nobody knows
exactly like Elisa Boyer I mean
obviously it's just her account of
things it's what happened between her
and cook it does sound plausible you
know what I'm saying now interestingly
though
there was um they had been in a
restaurant earlier like a place called
martonis like earlier on and Sam Cook
had been there like earlier on in the
night now according to people that
worked at this restaurant and friends of
his that had also been there they said
that Sam Cooke had like a big
um wad of cash like when he was at the
restaurant it wasn't shy about like
waving it around like look how much
money I got early you know what I mean
like kind of showing off or whatever but
they did search
um Elisa Boyer's purse
but they didn't find anything except
like a 20 Bill and then they searched
Sam Cook's car he had a Ferrari and all
he had was a money clip that had 108
dollars in it so they don't know where
that big wad of cash went and he spent
that or if you know or if he didn't have
that if like the people the restaurant
were mistaken or whatever yeah
I only had a couple hundred bucks in
there just seemed like a lot yeah maybe
it's probably a bunch of ones yeah it's
like I got there this big pork roll is
like one dollar bills that's like that's
what I would do I'm like 100 here you
know what I mean he's got [__] 51.
who wants to be 100 and a couple of
twenties around the other side
sounds like sounds like to me so far
pretty plausible
he's [__] got his Ferrari and he's
[__] wine and dying and he's [__]
picking up chicks
and he's [__] drunk out of his gourd
and he thinks he's [__] ladies man he
said oh no babe you're not going home
you're coming home you're coming with me
the hotel
and he gets there to acts of ass and
then she's got to run from him
and he's running where'd she go where'd
she go you shot me that sounds plausible
I mean yeah it's like some stupid [__]
that a guy would get in get involved in
yeah and he was like I said he seemed
like he was very very drunk yeah
um so yeah
so uh so these ladies man that night I
guess so you know it's
Sam Cook's friends and supporters and
everything like that like obviously they
didn't really want to believe this story
um but the police didn't really have any
reason to question it they said look the
timing of all the phone calls and
everything like that lined up uh they
actually gave birth to Franklin and
Evelyn Carr
um polygraph tests and they both passed
um so yeah you know why would the why
would the motel manager shoot him and
what motive would you have right that's
what I mean so so that's what I had her
she didn't know who he was didn't know
what was going on [__] scared she
shot him
and yeah I mean he just busts yeah he
just busted he needed harm he was just
looking for that girl yeah like I said
she ran away he was in trouble yeah and
like I said he seemed like he was like
pretty drunk like everything they were
talking about so he wasn't really
thinking clearly obviously he [__]
not stepped his [__] boundaries you
know
push that chick too far
alcohol
yeah it's a hell of a drug alcohol and
probably [__] a lot of a lot of uh
damn ego
maybe yeah I got a Ferrari I'm famous
yeah so it could have been that too yeah
but the thing about it is that um like I
said some of his supporters were a
little bit mad because they well they
were mad that the police didn't really
investigate they basically just said you
know they they took everybody's
statements everything seemed to line up
they did polygraph tests everybody
passed so they're pretty much like okay
well it's justifiable homicide you know
she shot him in self-defense she was in
fear of her life and they didn't really
see any reason to she's also at her
place of business yeah to question that
so yeah
so there but okay so but there have been
stories though because he had like some
famous friends and supporters
um Muhammad Ali thought it was very uh
suspicious that they didn't investigate
his death to any great degree that they
were just like oh justifiable homicide
Case Closed
um so he thought that was a little odd
he was like you know if this had been
like another famous person that was
perhaps white maybe they would have like
looked into it a little bit more
um another friend of his who's very
famous singer Etta James she actually
said
that before the funeral she went and
looked at the body
and she said that the body looked more
[__] up than what the police like what
the official version of events was she
said that he was beaten up really bad
and she's like and this whole thing was
like the woman just shot him one time
and then hit him on the head with a
broomstick or something like that he
said he looked all [__] up like his
head was almost off and like his
hands and fingers were like all broken
and [__] like that like he'd been in a
like some kind of fight or somebody had
beat the [__] out of him
but I mean I'm not casting aspersions
like maybe she did see that but I was
lit I was listening to this one
documentary and this guy had a really
good point he's like I feel like if this
was an open casket funeral which it was
as far as I know it's like no funeral
director in America would have let a
body go out like that like they would
have fixed it
so I don't know if she actually went to
see the body like before it was before
the funeral director
did it like you know fixed it up because
they don't she's remembering it wrong or
maybe I don't know she just saw that
body and it it it it it it it freaked
her out hi Pokey she saw the body that
freaked her out maybe she was imagining
that it looked all [__] up she'd never
seen a dead body before because like I
said I don't they were lifeless looking
they look like mannequins they
definitely would not like have an open
casket funeral if you look like you'd
been beat the [__] out if they would fix
it up at least or they would if or if
they couldn't fix it up they would not
have the open casket General emotions
got to it maybe so like I said I'm just
saying that that was the story like I
don't think she was the only one that
said that
um and like I said I don't know if they
went and saw the body like before the
funeral director like before the
mortician like did anything to it and
they were just kind of like yeah that
that body looks like somebody beat the
[__] out of them so I don't really know
but so the big story about this like I
said now some people have said because
he was like all up in the Civil Rights
Movement everything like that they might
have been killed because of that and
then there was like this big story was
like this big cover-up or whatever
but probably the most
um
uh uh the story that's told the most
about him like if the whole like
justifiable homicide thing was not the
case was just like the cover story is
that they think
that Sam Cook's manager whose name was
Alan Klein
um didn't actually kill himself but
maybe like had him killed
because Alan Klein
um he owned Tracy limited and this was a
company that he started with Sam Cook he
had a thing where he would um he would
start a company that was like the middle
man between the artist and the big
record companies and he would like
pay uh you know he they would produce
all the records and he would like pay
the royalties to the artist and then he
would sell the records to to so it was
kind of it was kind of a weird
system like they didn't usually do that
but um but it was very very lucrative
now he paid the artist like a lot of
money but he also paid himself a lot of
money and sometimes he skimmed a lot
like off the top because he did it to
the Beatles and he did it to The Rolling
Stones as well and they both sued him
over it
so Alan Klein What He did apparently was
when him and Sam Cook started Tracy
limited which was supposed to be this
music publishing company which was
supposed to like you know give Sam Cook
ostensibly like all the rights to all of
his music was that Alan Klein
wrote in the contract that
he it was like this real convoluted
wording and all this other kind of stuff
that he used where it essentially just
said well he was the owner of the
company and Sam Cook was just like an
employee of the company kind of so he
kind of worded it like that but in a way
that made it seem like they were both
the owners you know what I mean so he
was like kind of sneaky like that
so he um certainly made a lot of money
from uh Sam Cook's death for sure
so Alan Klein I mean I don't you know I
don't like to accuse anybody of anything
especially he's dead like he died in
2009 the thing about it was that the the
company that he founded like Tracy
records that the one that he started
with Sam Cook that was later folded into
his main company which is called ABCO
music and Records Incorporated which is
still around and owns a lot of you know
really high profile the music of a lot
of really high profile artists
so like what he did
um he uh got in trouble well it doesn't
he didn't get in trouble but he got sued
um with he was uh you know managed the
Rolling Stones
and he what he did the Rolling Stones
got 1.25 million dollars from Deca
records like an advance on their album
in 1965. and Alan Klein worked it so he
took that 1.25 million dollars and
deposited it into a company that he set
up and he made it the the contract said
that he didn't have to give them that
money for 20 years so he did [__] like
that damn
um he did [__] like that to The Beatles
too
um and they both separately like it said
there were like lots of lawsuits
um you know so he was not a real popular
dude like all the [__] that he was
pulling like he would uh withhold
royalty payments
um he owned the rights to a bunch of
their songs like I think for a long time
the Rolling Stones wouldn't do any of
their old songs because he owned all the
rights to them and they couldn't do them
or they didn't want to give him any
money
um he also like didn't pay their taxes
for five years like he was supposed to
so yeah so they went back and forth with
him like uh a lot so he actually had to
foreign
the IRS was like after him for a really
long time
and they finally did catch up to him uh
in 1980
but all he got was two months oh it was
like a misdemeanor like for making a
false statement on a tax return in 1972
and that's all he did so because he was
such a shady character
allegedly
um some people have speculated that he
might have had Sam Cook killed
particularly because Sam Cook had had
very recently like a day or two before
he was shot
um had an argument with Alan Klein
because he's like look I know what
you're up to and I'm getting rid of your
ass
um and like I said Alan Klein was making
a lot of money
from the company that he had set up with
Sam Cook so some people have speculated
that maybe uh this whole thing was kind
of like a cover-up in a sense like so
you know he could kill him I don't know
if I believe that seems a little
far-fetched
um to me it sounds like pretty much what
it seems like you know dudes out at a
nightclub gets drunk picks up a girl uh
gets
um
overzealous and she's like [__] this I'm
out of here and then he gets a little
bit upset and gets shot I'm just looking
for that chick it happens
um I think he thought he was in trouble
oh [__] no he was in trouble where'd she
go I mean she ran I before well she ran
and called the cops before she knew he
got shot yeah like because she ran out
the motel and because she was that was
like attempted rape probably would have
got he probably wouldn't have got shot
if he had clothes on
although he did well yeah I'm sure that
didn't help he did like come at her
though yeah he's like apparently yeah
like apparently he grabbed her and was
like where is that girl she's like how
the [__] would I know yeah
but yeah so that it was just um that's a
very unfortunate situation all around
um you know but like I said even that
day
yeah and it was his last one too so you
know you gotta watch
you never can't tell what's gonna happen
yeah but yeah so I I don't really see
you know I'm not saying that Alan Klein
sounds like a stand-up guy or nothing
like that because he sounds like like I
said he sounds like pretty shady but is
it is he Shady enough to
have somebody killed and then make it
look like an accident or yeah it's hard
to do it is yeah you could have paid
that woman to shoot him right and put
herself in Jeopardy over over some money
no she wouldn't die
yeah I I just don't I just don't
wouldn't have looked like that
if you wanted him dead he just they just
never would have found him
yeah yeah Mr 88 said Alan Klein is a
piece of [__] he screwed The Beatles in
the last stage of their career yeah he
screwed a lot of people
um and I'm just amazed that the two
months is all the prison time he ever
did because apparently I was reading his
Wikipedia page I'm like holy crap I like
the [__] that he did I mean I think that
was mostly like the you know the highest
profile stuff was like the Rolling
Stones of The Beatles Because they just
kept suing the [__] out of him but he
never did really get in trouble and he
keep getting business
I don't know to be honest and like I
said the company that he founded is
still around yeah and still owns like a
lot of music
I guess it was the kind of thing where
there's no internet so you couldn't the
word couldn't get out that he did it it
was a crook new artist is just stumbling
through the front door thinking oh this
is a famous company and then they got
you yeah
um yeah regenerate son says Etta James I
questioned something she said even in
her book not calling her a liar though
yeah it's just like I you know maybe she
was just upset I mean that was her
friend and she saw him dead and that is
really traumatic I'm sure but I just
kind of feel like if she just went right
before the funeral and saw the body like
in the coffin at the funeral I'm like
there's no way that they're gonna like
let a beat to [__] looking dude like lay
in a coffin like for everybody to look
at that's not gonna happen because she
was like oh it looked like his
hands were all broken and his head was
almost off and stuff like that I'm like
they don't not gonna let a body go out
there like that unless it's a closed
casket you know what I mean
nightmares or rainbow said would you
guys be interested in doing an episode
or a series of episodes on the hypocrisy
of the church because I would really
like to see that
um I had been thinking about doing a
show about like scandals of the Catholic
church although I think that's a massive
massive topic
um I'm not sure it would probably be
like [__] 15 hours long
but you know that but yeah that actually
would be something I might be interested
in doing but like I said I'd have to
like narrow it down into little more
manageable chunks even the scandals of
the Catholic Church one I keep having it
in my list and I'm just kind of like man
I'm just maybe I'll save that one for
when I have more time to do research you
know what I mean because I'd have to
like narrow down like a few
[__] jet Manny Nicole said yeah I
mean everyone looks bad in the casket
yeah I mean pretty much No One's Gonna
look all super beautiful like after
they're dead you know what I mean
they're all gonna look a little bit
funny
so all right so let's talk about Jimi
Hendrix
now you know a bit about Jimi Hendrix
yeah is it the same unit as him you were
yeah 100 because he was in the military
I don't know if a lot of people yeah he
was he was uh in the 101st during the
Vietnam era
um I think he was I think he did two
years
um
but uh he got hurt on a [__] training
job he never deployed to Vietnam
because his his physical profile
yeah he was in one of the parachute
regiments
but um they didn't deploy parachute
regiments to me
Vietnam they put him in helicopters it
was probably before the conversion
but he was
I've read letters
um that he wrote he liked the Army he
said he had a lot of fun in it but uh it
drove him crazy that he couldn't have a
guitar I didn't have time to play yeah
now he did eventually get a guitar
and he played uh some of his first shows
outside the 101 club for Campbell and
there's a bronze Monument to Jimi
Hendrix
and it's got his real name I think it
was James
Hendricks was his names it is spelled
different
private J and this is private James
Hendricks played before his first live
audience here to give a date
and um
so he he was an honored Soldier
you know it was funny because
this is during the Vietnam he started to
become famous during the Vietnam
era and uh
remember Dick Cavett tried to get him to
basically say something bad
about the war and the troops and he
wouldn't do it he just says you don't
understand what those guys are going
through my heart goes out to all of them
I know what they're going through he
wouldn't talk bad about the troops which
so he kind of got endeared he was the
Army liked him
he kind of went down as a legend
everybody knew that that was a [__] up
Mission you know there's no way to win
that it was just a big police action and
they were using those dudes as bait
but you don't want to rub salt in the
wound you know what I mean
he really he got a really good song
called machine gun and it's it's about
the Vietnam War you guys can listen to
it they made some guys that made some
really good tribute videos to it showing
slow motion color photography and film
Vietnam conflict
bombs exploded and [__] Jimi Hendrix
talking about machine gun weighing him
down
breaking his body all up you're talking
about the carrying the M60 which I was
M60 Gunner for a while
and um yeah it did break your body
that's what it felt like he talks about
it
but he was he didn't deploy he was he
sent those songs he said he made that
song for those guys who did deploy
he captured it he captured the feeling
of it
yeah so
um
yeah Jimi hendrix's last name was
actually Hendrix Hendrix no spelled
exactly the same not with an X yeah is
that with a x yeah according to my notes
Here I think it was spelled like like a
normal Hendrix
but he was James Marshall Andrew James
Marshall that's right
so the controversy surrounding his death
which actually I watched a couple
documentaries about this too
um is that some people think that he
actually like committed suicide on
purpose and there is also
um some people that think that again his
manager might have killed him now I will
say that in this case it does sound a
little more
plausible
um still a little out there but he had a
lot more
allegedly his manager had a lot more
reason
to kill him and there was like some
weird [__] about
um how he died exactly like because
there's differing
um accounts of you know Pathologists and
things like that which was kind of like
some weird [__] so maybe like I said I
still don't know and I don't know
they're not actually entirely sure if he
if he killed himself on purpose
or if it was an accident
so there's that too and a lot of people
too there's also a lot of controversy
about it a controversy about his
girlfriend Monica dannerman who was
there with him at the time who let's
just say that
um
her uh over the years like she kept
changing the story of like what exactly
happens like when she found him and
stuff so that's a little fishy as well
so I don't know exactly what happened
but we'll talk about it a little bit
so we'll get just a little bit of a
background obviously
um yeah so like I said Lauren James
Marshall Hendricks in 1942 in Seattle
uh and joined his first band at 13 years
old they said interestingly when he was
a teenager
um the people that were in a band with
him they didn't really uh he wasn't
super charismatic they said he was very
very shy and he didn't have any stage
presence and stuff like that so a lot of
the people that knew him when he was
younger were actually like really
surprised at how he turned out because
that wasn't really what he was like when
he was a teenager so he joined the army
he actually dropped out of high school
and joined the army
uh and had a band while he was in the
Army called the king casuals uh he was
honorably discharged in 1962 and then
started playing with Little Richard
Jackie Wilson Wilson Pickett stuff like
that
um now a year before he died
he actually uh was on trial in Toronto
for a possession of heroin and hash
but he uh was not convicted now he did
admit to using LSD hash cocaine and
marijuana uh but he did not he uh always
denied that he used heroin and indeed I
will kind of skip ahead and say uh the
autopsy that they did on him which I
read like the um you know breakdown of
the autopsy report uh they found
absolutely no evidence that he had ever
done heroin like no track marks no
nothing like that so so that would seem
to be the case
so
um so yeah Hendrix liked acid yeah he
was and he did admit like to doing all
the other drugs but he was like yeah I
didn't really do heroin and like I said
there was on at the autopsy there was no
uh evidence he had ever done heroin
so here's the thing okay so this is kind
of the account the official account and
this is from uh an author named Tony
Brown who wrote a book called Jimi
Hendrix the final days
and he's like in this
there's Jimi Hendrix as a paratrooper in
the 101st
zombie you wouldn't even recognize him I
wouldn't recognize him without his hair
like with the helmet on and not in the
clothes that he was normally wearing
yeah that's him right there
okay now like with his unit yeah
okay so that's a picture of it
yeah it's kind of a little more
recognized but with short hair it's it's
hard it's harder and without it yeah but
it's like that that smile though is like
real it was tall
yeah she's all spoken
he does really good interviews you can
see old interviews up in the 70s on talk
shows he's he's a nice guy
yeah and like I and I as far as I know
like everybody that knew him said that
he was just a lovely person like that
yeah it's just a real nice gentle yeah
dude friendly intelligent guy
real talented
self-taught My Guitar
played left-handed even though he's a
right-handed guy
just just what he did it broke all rules
he invented basically he invented heavy
metal and and Industrial
if you have that third Stone if you have
that the Jimi Hendrix experience that
first album
there's a song on there called third
Stone from the Sun
guitar tracks are backwards and there's
a lot of backwards stretched out tracks
in it
and that's what inspired skinny Poppy
to do that kind of stuff
and it does kind of sound Industrial
even this is way ahead of his time now
he had some British band mates that were
also with Noel Redding I think what was
that guy's name [__] I forgot the other
I think Noel Redding was one of the guys
names
but they were they were real talented
too they were just a good Trio
they were so ahead of their times most
people rejected them when they first
played them when they first heard them
well that usually happens in America
they didn't like him he was big and he
was big in Europe Germany and England he
got big there first his band was from
England
he couldn't recruit America's to play
with him he was too weird but he was on
to some good [__] man [__] his music
still stands to the test of time
especially when he bought that electric
ladyland studio and came out with that
electric ladyland double album that [__]
was [__] badass I had all of his
albums and some of his bootlegs back
when I was teenager
you still got some of them yes
I just saw him yeah Zach says I got uh
um access bold is love
a pristine album
is it like 100 a great album
Zach said I always thought Hendrix was
pretty hot yeah I agree
uh Mr 88 said Hendricks is also famous
for having been screwed by his label
which was MCA yeah I kind of feel like
that happened uh a lot back and probably
still that probably still happens
but yeah any anytime you're talking
about that much money yeah they're gonna
try and like [__] [__] you over
because they're gonna be like ah they're
just the creative
they don't know anything about business
so we can [__] them over
so yeah that happens a lot
so all right
so this is kind of like
the the official version of what
happened on like his last days I guess
so right around September of 1970.
um Jimi Hendrix had been he was kind of
having a hard time like he had um he'd
been having like real bad insomnia he
had like a real bad um flu
like I don't know if it was pneumonia
but it was something like that uh he was
real stressed out overworked stuff like
that
so
um he had a German girlfriend at the
time his name was Monica damerman yeah
she was hot too she
yeah she um she also died she died in uh
1996 I want to say uh suicide they think
uh they found her in her car like you
know carbon monoxide poisoning
but yeah so we'll get into that in a
second
um but so they were at her uh
apartment and it's what is it the
Samarkand Samarkand Hotel yeah
so they drank some tea they had some
hash
uh and they're you know they're at her
place and then they had some dinner
now at one point during the night uh
they think that Jimi Hendrix called
someone uh possibly his lawyer I think
maybe to talk about getting out of his
relationship with his manager Mike
Jeffrey who a lot of people think maybe
had something to do with him dying
allegedly
so uh apparently him and his girlfriend
uh had uh they kind of split a bottle of
red wine like over a few hours
and then Jimi Hendrix goes and gets in
the tub for a little while
now one of his uh friends business
associates whatever his name was P
Cameron he was actually having a party
that night and I don't think Jimmy was
all that jazz about going but he's like
well I kind of feel like I have to so
they did
now when he was at the party
um he had at least one amphetamine
tablet a black bomber so they know that
he had that they did find it in his
system like afterwards
now while they were at the party several
witnesses said that uh he and Monica
appeared to have a an argument uh she
was apparently really upset about
something it was like you know I need to
talk to you right now and he was getting
kind of annoyed because he said that she
wouldn't leave him alone I think what
they were fighting about was that um he
kind of had more than one girlfriend
sort of like on on again off again and I
think that he had been talking to one of
those uh ladies like earlier on in the
evening and I think she was like mad
about her like jealous about it
according to one witness actually
somebody heard her call him a [__]
pig at some point during the night like
while they were at the party
so um they ended up leaving the party at
three in the morning
now
according to Monica who was the only
person who was there when Jimi Hendrix
died apparently
she said they got home after sometime
around three o'clock in the morning she
said she made them each a tuna sandwich
and then they wanted to go to sleep but
Jimmy had taken the amphetamine and it
was keeping him awake so he couldn't go
to sleep
he apparently asked her if she could if
he could have some of her sleeping pills
but she said no
um now
by the time it was like six in the
morning she actually kind of snuck and
took one herself apparently
now according to her she woke up four
hours later
um so like well here's the thing
she said 10 or 11 A.M but the time that
she woke up and that she it kind of like
the story changed like a lot of times
but she says about four hours later she
woke up and Jimi Hendrix was fine he was
asleep
she said that she left the apartment to
buy cigarettes
and that when she came back Jimmy was
unconscious she said that he was still
alive at this point
um in some stories she said that he had
vomited and she was like trying to wake
him up but she couldn't wake him up so
she called the paramedics
now paramedics arrived at the house at
11 27 am
now when they got there at 11 27 A.M
the door to the apartment was wide open
uh the curtains were drawn the little
gas fire was on Monica was not there
they said that there was no one in the
apartment but Jimi Hendrix and that when
they got there he was already dead
like they obviously they came in and
they tried to like they said that there
was
um I believe one of the First Responders
called the scene quote-unquote vile he
said that he was just like covered with
like black and brown vomit
um they said that his Airway was
completely clogged and closed all the
way down to his lungs and that it
appeared that he had been dead for quite
a while
so they actually called the cops
um because they thought it was weird one
that he was already dead and two that
Monica Who had who had called The First
Responders uh was not there anymore so
they didn't know where she went to
um
so they took him to uh the hospital
now according to the doctor who was kind
of there when he came in this is a quote
he said he was cold and he was blue on
admission he was obviously dead he had
no pulse no heartbeat and the attempt to
resuscitate him was merely a formality
that's what he said so they knew that he
was already dead and like I said the um
the ambulance guy said that too that he
was clearly already dead when they got
there
um and he looked like he had been dead
for a little while
now the coroner didn't find any evidence
of suicide
Monica later said that she had counted
um her sleeping pills because remember
he asked her for sleeping pills and she
didn't give him any but the implication
was that he had taken them later like
without her knowing so she said that she
counted
the pills later on and that there were
nine of them missing I think at one
point she said there were 10 of them
missing but most of the sources said
that she said nine of them were missing
nine of these pills which are called uh
vesperax I think they're called
um is 18 times the recommended dose
uh so that's a lot
even though he probably had a a
tolerance pretty healthy tolerance right
like that still
your body can only take so much when you
have all this other [__] yeah
and uh you don't want to mix uppers and
downers just not a good idea yeah
especially if you [__] fall asleep
and you start
getting sick
you can't wake up to clear your own
Airway yeah
that's what happened to him that's
probably what happened yeah yeah he just
[__] started throwing up
because of all the [__] he's been
drinking and eating at tonight
and he didn't wake up just inhaled his
own vomit yeah
so
yeah and that's fine Scott too I
remember correctly lead singer of AC DC
happened in the back of his limousine
passed out sitting up they left him up
left him sitting up in there and he
passed out vomited into himself and it
killed him
yeah which is like yeah well that's what
I mean it's just like it's so [__] up
because it seems like such a dumb like
easy
way to die it's just it just seems like
humans are so [__] fragile man that's
all you have to do is just like throw up
with your head back
though man we're talking about the 60s
and the 70s these [__] rock stars
were out of [__] control uh yeah big
time uh they were lucky to make it to
their 30s a lot of them didn't
they
rampant uncontrolled [__] sex and
drugs
all [__] night like I said I'm always
shocked that some of them actually lived
into old age yeah and the girls were
like that too Janice everybody was like
that that girl from [__] Jefferson
Airplane they said that Jay just
couldn't hear gray slip yeah they
couldn't keep dicks out of her she just
said she was just a [__] walking
brothel
constantly [__] drunk and high and
they were all like that they were just
out of control
it was not a time of moderation
well it was almost like I kind of feel
like everybody everybody had been so
repressed for so long that everybody was
like busted her they just like went way
over the top with it until everybody was
like all right let's just dial it back a
couple like you can still go out party
and have fun and everything like that
but let's not choke on our own vomit
okay I think several decades of [__]
unleaded gasoline built up
high lead content in them
which made everybody extreme
made people [__] violent and Thrill
Seekers
um
and there wasn't a lot to do you know
[__] you can see a concert or a movie
listen to the radio watch TV and that
was shitty and there were a lot of drugs
laying around there wasn't any internet
or video games so yeah what else was
there to do the main social media was
[__] music and Records yeah me and
Jen remember it there was no [__]
internet if you wanted to find out what
people like you were doing you had to go
get a record out
and then you through the lyrics that was
and that was how you found your people
that's how you found your tribe you've
been walking around somewhere and see
somebody with a t-shirt or that band
you're my friend for life yeah
yeah you know that nobody else does that
so it was just that was the social media
at the time so these dudes
it was very cool to be a rock star
during this uh era and it got cool it
got cool as it went got cooler as it
went on
it wasn't until recently be a rock star
it's not that not as cool as it was they
don't make rock stars really like they
used to
those guys are all dying off and the
thing about it too is that I I must
imagine that you know in hindsight
you're talking about like how crazy it
was like all these shows and everybody
was so like off their faces that nobody
knew what was happening and stuff like
that but like at the time I imagine it
wasn't uh it wasn't a party like having
to deal with
you know Jim Morrison for example no I'm
sure he was not fun to deal with no he'd
have been a pain in the ass that's what
I mean well and the other guys in the
doors were just kind of like we're kind
of over this man it's like he's just
[__] he's [__] up all the time he
was very talented to be very full of
himself
he was he was very troubled yeah a lot
of them yeah he was just constantly
drunk and he took other drugs too but
his main thing was he was a drunk yeah
that was you know they said yeah every
now and then like he took some other
[__] like LSD and everything like that
but mostly he was just wanting to drink
am I reading a Hendrix
is that
he took a lot of LSD lots of it yeah but
LSD doesn't have an overdose point you
can take lots of it until you just lose
your mind you can't do anything you just
lay there yeah but it won't kill you
um yeah not in the way like heroin will
and evidently that was the main one that
he did
and his record company
really from what I remember reading
about it they weren't really worried
about him dying of of drugs well they
were worried about is him killing
himself in that [__] Corvette that he
bought
yeah he had this [__] badass [__]
like 72 Corvette it was supposed to be
this [__] maxed out
and uh he would [__]
drive it around California to [__]
110 miles an hour on [__] Pacific
Coast Highway which that's not really
yeah he was either he drove very fast
and uh a lot of times they're the
influence of things
so they were they kind of were like
trying to take the keys probably of all
the time afraid he'd get killed I mean
you can't blame him yeah that badass
[__]
I think I remember exactly what happened
to the to the Corvette
I think maybe they made him sell it
I think they made him sell it if I
remember correctly
but uh
yeah and and Jim Morrison wasn't allowed
to drive at all
he couldn't have a car yeah that he had
he was just perpetually they had him
whose their whole job was to make sure
he never got to a [__] car a lot of
his girlfriends were being paid
to keep him from driving
well because the thing about it is like
he would you know obviously they
wouldn't they might not just kill
themselves they might kill other [__]
innocent people too yeah the record
companies didn't care about that though
they cared about well yeah obviously but
I'm just saying obviously but other
people probably right regular people
with Souls actually cared about that
yeah didn't have souls no that's what
I'm saying
I'm just saying people would like his
friends and stuff yeah
Mr 88 says Tom Jimmy was left-handed but
he played a right-handed guitar in a
left-handed orientation that's what it
was strung upside down okay because
right-handed guitars were hard to find
okay is that what it was I just remember
it looked crazy as a [__] okay I
thought he was right hand maybe yeah
you're right you're right there's a
right left thing that's I I just kind of
got forgot the details there's a
right-handed guitar that he was playing
left-handed yeah Mr 88 said even more
weird uh Dick Dale uh King of the surf
guitar obviously is also left-handed but
learned to play on a right-handed guitar
so he played guitar strong upside down
for his entire life to my knowledge The
Only Name player in the world to do so
as a guitar player I cannot fathom how
you would play guitar strong upside down
either
to be honest with you I never learned
guitar I did learn a little bit of bass
when I was younger
but I mean I guess it's all in what you
get used to but Hendrix was very there's
a reason that most people still do that
I guess
Hendricks was uh
very influential in the sound in in rock
and in metal
because he was trying to do things other
people were trying to avoid doing like
he was trying to get Distortion out of
an electric guitar other other artists
were trying to avoid Distortion so he he
actually
contracted people to make Distortion and
I think there were little custom shops
guitar shops sprung up to make guitar
effects like little distortion pedals
and flange pedals to get certain sounds
that today you take for granted if I
remember correctly that was Jim it was
that was Jimi Hendrix
that really
spurred on the creation of guitar
effects
that you take for granted there would
have been no Eddie Van Halen without
Jimi Hendrix there would have been no
but definitely okay yeah definitely no
no Eddie Van there would have been no
Black Sabbath without Hendrix
and I would say Black Sabbath was
probably the first metal band
even though it's kind of like Blues but
sometimes I say the [__] Hendrix was
the first medal some of the some some of
those songs I would say were metal
definitely invented the guitar solo
Mr 88 said the late 60s was the most
culturally and creatively fertile period
in U.S history and by a long long way
too yeah I don't I don't think you'd get
too much disagreement on that
um Sebastian said uh he was a screaming
eagle was that your mob Tom yeah I got a
[__] tattoos yeah he mentioned that
earlier yeah yeah that was his that was
his unit Zach said um my dad's been an
amateur guitarist basically his whole
life and he tried teaching me but much
like learning a new language and Algebra
I just never got it
[Laughter]
yeah it's um I used to play piano when I
was younger
and I did play a little bit of bass but
um I just I didn't keep it up so I could
probably learn it again if I yeah
buckled down but another interesting
thing about Hendricks is that Hendricks
believed in UFOs
he believed in extraterrestrials he
thought UFOs were common
some of his um
his uh custom-made effects pedals like
the Distortion and flange petals and
were made like UFOs flying saucers and
[__]
and if you were to ask Hendrix what kind
of music he was playing he would tell
you it was space music
I could see that outer space music yeah
it does kind of have that quality to it
yeah and uh so he succeeded in third
Stone and then on this in the song Third
Stone from the sun he says right there
he's talking about aliens watching the
[__] Earth and it was a grass
beautiful place of green your people I
had never seen and and to you I shall
give it unto the Earth
so you will never hear surf music again
so he was killing off surf music
and replacing this well that's funny
because mr88 just said Jimmy is the most
famous for guitar effects particularly
the fuzz and wah ironically the very
first use of fuzz was the ventures a
surf band okay yeah
well just go listen to third Stone from
the sun he says you will never hear surf
music again it's gonna be [__] flying
saucers
space music
you mentioned some aqua castles castles
in the sand I think as references to
[__] UFOs in it
extraterrestrials
Michael says that's true Grace Slick
loved [__] yeah I've heard that hey
nothing wrong with that oh they said
that she just
couldn't keep it out of her every time
he turned around it was just another
dude
every time you turn around you turn
around and it was like behind stage you
know they made like backstage like she
could maybe she's a nymphomaniac it's
like she's an info
[Music]
wasn't celebrities it was just random
dudes you know what I mean you just see
her back there just getting [__]
plowed and it was like three or four or
five of them a day
yeah it definitely sounds like
nymphomaniac yeah
yeah I've known a couple people like
that
like I said it's just
as long as everyone's adults and
consenting oh there's no problem with it
just you know be careful but
other than that I don't I don't I'm not
I'm not judging about it you know what I
mean
um but yeah okay so where was I all
right so
Jimi Hendrix pronounced that at 12 45
p.m great loss
um now the autopsy said obviously uh
asphyxiation on his own vomit uh you
know probably because of drugs or
whatever
um now they did do the the forensic
pathologist the autopsy report uh
actually called Jimi Hendrix
well-nourished and muscular uh again
said there was no evidence of heroin use
like no track marks anything like that
um and he also found a collapse left
lung uh 400 milliliters of fluid in
Henderson's chest uh vomit in the lungs
also and he was young man 27. it did
never reach his full potential nope and
he just bought that [__] Studio he
was one of the first rock stars to buy
his own recording studio called electric
ladyland he was gonna
sponsor other bands and make his own he
made his first double album out of that
studio he had a great future ahead of
him it was just a the tragedy
because who knows what he would have
been
10 15 20 years down the line
imagine Hendricks
[__] playing on David Bowie albums
[__] like that could have happened see
that would have been fantastic yeah it'd
have been real good imagine if the scary
monsters album didn't have Robert Fripp
it had [__] Jimi Hendrix on it
oh
somebody on YouTube that can play like
Jimi Hendrix like yeah make that happen
I'm now I'm kind of because that's a
perfect match
not just scary monsters with [__]
Jimi Hendrix or fashion with Jimi
Hendrix playing yeah yeah now that you
bring that up like I said if somebody
that could do those Styles like could
replicate the whatever it might sound
like that would be really interesting
um yeah so now they said here is the
interesting thing
so his blood alcohol level
was
um 100 milligrams per 100 milliliters so
it's like that was about they said about
the equivalent of four pints of beer so
a lot but not that much they said you
would still fail a breathalyzer like you
couldn't breathe uh or nothing like that
but it's not like enough to kill you now
they did think that what had happened
was that he had indeed taken those nine
sleeping tablets yeah
and he had also had uh the amphetamine
like earlier yeah and there was also
they also found some pot but no no no no
probably nothing but they
Pro they thought it was because of the
um the sleeping tablets yeah and alcohol
and the alcohol
and then it magnifies the effects of
alcohol right
um now they said that they're they
didn't see any evidence of an intention
to commit suicide
um but they're not entirely sure of that
so they left it an open verdict no he
was just drunk I think it was probably
just like I wanted to go to sit down so
he grabbed a whole bunch of pills and
[__] put it in his mouth maybe I mean
the thing about it like some people have
said oh it's like because he left this
poem
um that kind of sounded like a suicide
note but then Eric burden from the
animals who was like a friend of his who
has the poem now and he's just like yeah
but I mean I have like a bunch of his
writings and stuff and there was a bunch
of his stuff that sounded like songs and
poems that he wrote that could have been
you know perceived as a suicide note so
he didn't necessarily no she's not
suicidal
yeah now they did say like I said he'd
been sick and he was like well worn out
and stressed out and everything like
that so you know but I don't think I
don't know I think it was probably just
an accident he had he had too many uh
he had he had a lot of plans of what he
was going to do in the future and he had
a lot of projects that he was going to
do and um yeah touring was getting to
him but he was living a good life he had
a good girlfriend uh he he was crazy
about it and she and she uh looked out
for him and uh you know he was um
he had just come back from England he
where was this that he died again
um it was California
yeah it was wasn't it I think it was
California where he died
hey
yeah because electric ladyland was
around there
I think I think was near California
somebody might might want to check on
that I don't remember where the
locations of these places where he would
go on and I haven't read about him in a
long time
I just grew up knowing about these guys
but no he wasn't I know because London
it was London London is where it
happened okay sorry yeah
I had to go back and check because I
forgot to
he was dealing with a lot of [__] too
because back in the United States you
had like I said that whole civil rights
thing going on
and uh black people didn't like his
music
they kind of rejected him and I don't
think he liked that
because uh because it wasn't sold
you know what I mean and his fans were
mostly white and he was he was already
famous in Europe before Americans even
knew about him
so
he was kind of
more at home in in in England than in
Germany
people people loved him there
but I don't know there was no reason to
kill yourself though just because you
know what I mean you didn't have a
[__] black audience
yeah I mean I
there's no there's no [__] um
I don't remember reading anything that
said that he was upset about that
if he he was you how if you want work to
compare Jimi Hendrix with any more
modern artist maybe for a younger person
to compare him to
best comparison would be Prince he was
kind of like Prince
Prince
he kind of had a universal audience but
if you were to add up the numbers oh man
[__] white people made Prince he had
more white fans than anything because
they're just more white people
you know he was extremely popular
and um
he was like Prince but he was a little
bit ahead of his time
he wasn't sexual like Prince though
Prince was trying to you know what I
mean he was a [__] lover boy
Hendrix was just more like
tripping you out [__] a space man he was
cool
yeah you said he was gonna let his freak
flag wave high and [__]
weird [__] British fashion over the
top [__] hippie time wasn't even
really hippie it was just
60s fashion
he's real athletic like I said he
[__] dats
[__] jamming out to the guitar he
invented the guitar solo a lot of the
things you saw more modern guitarists do
Hendrix pioneered all that
played the damn national anthem on an
electric guitar and then set the guitar
on fire
and um it was patriotic you know what I
mean he was he wasn't some people some
of the people you know like older people
thought he was desecrating the
the [__] national anthem now man
[__] Hendrix was was expressing it
you know he was honoring it he was doing
doing it his way
I thought it was quite cool
a matter of fact it's recorded you can
watch it and play yeah it's famous it's
famous that's probably the most famous
rendition yeah and his whole [__] act
of doing the national the the doing the
national anthem on that guitar
inspired Rock and metal guitarist to do
the [__] moves that they were doing
during those solos they basically got
that [__] from Hendrix
getting on his knees and [__] you know
now you know other [__] came after that
but he was he was [__] very
Innovative yeah very innovative
I think he was more instrumental than
people give him credit for
oh yeah for sure yeah he was up there
with the Rolling Stones and beetles easy
easy
so yeah so even though it was an open
verdict
there have been some
other theories because uh the book I
mentioned earlier which is called Jimi
Hendrix the final days the author of
that it came out in the 90s by the way
the author of that Tony Brown he
actually stayed in contact with Monica
danaman
um for many years until she died in 1996
like I said she was found dead in her
car in uh East Sussex she was 50 years
old um and they assumed that she killed
herself carbon monoxide
um and they assumed that the reason
behind it was that she had been having a
court battle with another one of Jimi
hendrix's girlfriends his name is Kathy
etchingham and she had lost the case two
days prior to them to her being found
out
so one thing that Tony Brown the author
said
was that pretty much every time he
talked to Monica danaman about
um Jimi hendrix's final days and about
her finding him
um like what the events of that day were
um details changed like every single
time
um she basically said like in some
iterations she said we went to sleep at
seven in the morning I woke up at 11 his
face was covered with vomit and he was
but he was still breathing then she
called an ambulance and he got taken to
the hospital and then she noticed that
10 of her sleeping tablets were missing
that was one statement that she gave
and then
she said like another version of the
story same kind of thing they went to
sleep at seven she woke up at 11.
Jimmy's face was covered in vomit tried
to wake him up called
um an ambulance and he got taken to the
hospital but she went with him in the
ambulance to the hospital now
the the First Responders to this
absolutely categorically deny this
sequence of events Monica they said was
not there they went into the apartment
the door was wide open
and they went in there there was nobody
there except Jimi Hendrix on the bed and
he was already dead
but Monica daniman in some iterations of
the story that she told at various times
she would either usually say well at
first she didn't even say that oh I went
to get went out to get cigarettes like
and Jimmy was fine and then when I came
back he had he had vomit all over him
and then I couldn't wake him up
so she didn't even like add that detail
until later on but she kept saying that
she woke up at different times and then
she started saying that she went with
him in the ambulance to the hospital and
that he was still alive when he was
taken to the hospital and the First
Responders and the doctors and
everything like that said that is
absolutely not the case First Responders
said we got there nobody was there
except for him and he was already dead
like the door was open but she was not
there and then later on Eric burden from
the animals said that yeah Monica
daniman was with me she was not like so
she must have gone to see him like as
soon as she called the because she
called the ambulance and got the [__]
out she wasn't there
yeah look man this girl was probably
[__] high probably beside herself and
[__] panicking
and she's probably got the times all
[__] up
she probably [__] ran around like a
chicken with her head cut off I mean
yeah you would think I mean I am willing
to give people like the benefit of the
doubt because that's like your boyfriend
and yeah you know finding them dead it's
like really horrible she's probably like
man maybe I contributed to this dude's
death and I don't know it right maybe he
took my pills maybe I gave him a pill
maybe you know what I mean so she's
trying yeah she was probably afraid she
was gonna get in trouble yeah that's
probably what was going on and I think
this was not a homicide and it was not a
suicide it's a [__] accident
stupid amateur ass accident from a young
man in his 20s who thought he was
[__] invisible
you know taking those [__] pills he
didn't respect those pills
but he probably dumps like [__] like
that before but he was in a moment I
mean like I said he's taking amphetamine
earlier on at the party and then like a
few hours later like he apparently at
least according to her and that's pretty
much matches up with what they found at
the autopsy like he took way over yeah
the the recommended dose yeah sleeping
pills I was gonna say uh
um one thing that I one thing that I
noticed about
rock stars and just kind of like people
in general really cutting edge people of
the 1960s they did not have a healthy
respect for drugs
they're like oh I like that here I'll
take one well [__] I'll take 10. well
and they would just take random [__]
without even like people would just like
give him stuff and be like okay yeah and
they would take combinations of stuff
just because
it was there because it was there they
just didn't
I don't want to say they lacked
education but in a way they did they
kind of I think those drugs were
everywhere and they lacked the knowledge
of what that stuff could do to you in
certain dosages and certain
combinations you know
and maybe they'd get away with something
a couple times because they were young
but they couldn't get away with that
forever no until they eventually would
start pushing boundaries
and no your body can't do that you can
you know too much of this humans are
very fragile
um you know what I mean it doesn't
really take much in a lot of ways yeah
to [__] kill us like I said all you
got to do is drink too much and then
like fall asleep with your head back
like that and he probably had a pretty
good tolerance I would imagine and
Charlie took them kind of regularly but
just
[__] up that night took too much yeah
he was probably pushing the boundaries a
couple times before and didn't know
you know it just didn't have drug
awareness yeah like I said they would
just take anything it's like they didn't
really give a [__] yeah under the
effects of another drug
yeah like I said it's just because it
was there and it was everywhere so
they're just kind of like oh whatever
this is probably fun too but it's just
kind of like nobody really had any um
inkling of like what the [__] was you
were just taking [__] from random ass
people it's like you don't know what the
[__] was in there yeah and it's just
kind of like
and like you said they're probably
because they were young and they'd
gotten away with it a lot of times
before that'll be fine it'll be fine but
until that time when it's not fine
but yeah so
um so there was evidently because of
Monica danaman's um
ever-changing stories about what exactly
had happened uh one of his other
girlfriends
um Kathy etchingham she actually wanted
she hired a private investigator like in
the early 90s
um to like go back into his death and
they came up with enough like weird
inconsistencies that they actually
um went to the UK authorities and like
requested that the coroner's inquest be
reopened
um but they you know the the authorities
said now we don't really think that will
serve anyone's you know it just seemed
like it was an accidental overdose and
that was kind of the end of it yeah that
chick was just [__] high and scared
yeah however there is something really
weird about this
is that um in 2009 this book came out
um by a guy who had been a roadie for
Jimi Hendrix whose name was James tappy
Wright
and this book claimed
that Jimi Hendrix had been murdered by
his manager
according to tappy
um Michael Jeffrey his manager said to
him and I quote I had to do it tappy you
understand don't you I had to do it you
know damn well what I'm talking about I
was in London the night of Jimmy's death
and together with some old friends we
went round to Monica's hotel room got a
handful of pills and stuffed them into
his mouth then poured a few bottles of
red wine deep into his windpipe I had to
do it Jimmy was worth much more to be
dead than alive that son of a [__] was
going to leave me if I lost him I'd lose
everything sounds like [__] now one
thing about that though
uh one Jimi Hendrix was actually in
talks to get rid of his manager so
there's that Michael Jeffrey also took
out a two million dollar life insurance
policy on Jimi Hendrix not too long
before he died which is always a little
suspicious did he cash in on it um well
he I don't he might have but he died
like only a few years later yeah now it
another thing like I said that's not
that unusual because those dudes were
dying off pretty [__] cool yeah
but one thing that kind of like I said
that seems far-fetched although I'm
always suspicious when somebody takes
out like a big life insurance policy on
somebody like and then they suspiciously
die yeah but Rockstar by the time well I
know that but I'm just saying but
another thing that was kind of
interesting and I was watching a
documentary where they had um
uh the surgeon who was uh trying to
revive Jimi Hendrix when they brought
him to the hospital when he was already
dead and he said that like in the thing
he's like he was already dead we were
trying to bring him back but it was just
that was just what you do but we knew he
wasn't coming back from anything
um his name is John Bannister and he
said that he's like yeah he's like the
official cause of death is like he
choked on his own vomit but he's like
more specifically
he drowned in red wine
even though there was very little red
wine in his blood you know what I mean
yeah
um he says and this is a quote from the
surgeon he says I recall vividly the
very large amounts of red wine that
oozed from his stomach and his lungs and
in my opinion there was no question that
Jimi Hendrix had drowned if not at home
then on his way to the hospital
so he seemed to be implying that he
thought it's like it didn't look like he
had drunk that much wine but that
somebody had like poured it in his mouth
you know what I mean yeah so I mean he
didn't say that outright but that seemed
to be what he was implying because he
just thought it was very strange
drinking that night though he was yeah
but not enough to
he's saying not enough to account for
the amount of red wine that he saw
leeching out of his organs and stuff
like that I think it's unlikely he was
murdered which yeah I'm just saying that
but I'm just saying that's you know it's
the mysteries of rock and roll so I'm
just saying this I'm not saying I
necessarily believe that
um but that is a very common uh rumor
about his death and they think that if
that's the case then maybe his manager
had um had motive to do that allegedly
allegedly well like I said his managers
he probably did yeah he is dead I think
he died only three years after um Jimi
Hendrix did uh I think
if I'm not uh mistaken I think yeah I
think he died in 1973. so yeah um and we
brought it up before and like I said we
kind of talked about this in our first
mysteries of uh rock and roll show but
uh yeah Jimi Hendrix another member of
the 27 Club
um along with uh you know
Jim Morrison who we're going to talk
about in a minute
um you know Kurt Cobain Amy Winehouse uh
you know but like I said I was looking
at like a statistical breakdown of that
and it is actually not any more common
for rockstars to die at 27 then
I because I was reading that it's like
there's also another cluster of rock
stars that died when they were 25 and
stars that died when they were 32.
so 27 there's like nothing magical about
the number 27 it just happened that like
a a bunch of like really high profile
people died at that age but it's not
like statistically
significant you know what I mean the guy
from the Stooges died when he was 27
also
um
but yeah so
I don't know like I said I I don't know
it is pretty weird about the the life
insurance policy and the red wine thing
um that is pretty weird but I imagine
that this is probably exactly what it
looked like
um and I don't think he was trying to
kill himself either I don't I don't
think it was I just think it was an
accident
you know he'd been drinking that night
he was on amphetamines he was kind of
tired or worn out or whatever and he
just took too many sleeping pills and
and [__] happened you know like I was
gonna talk about Jim Morrison yeah no
we're going to talk about Jim Morrison
right now and somebody said uh
brought up
uh Michael
Kaminsky I think is what his name is Sir
Nikki oh I can't I don't have my glasses
though
he says Steve Ray Vaughan [__] smokes
Hendrix all right
I saw Stephen Ray Vaughan Pine Knob
theater
and that couldn't stand the weather tour
I think in the 1986 maybe 87 I think it
was 86.
man he was [__] great live
fantastic show
yeah Stevie Ray Vaughan [__] smoke
Hendrix but he came much later you know
and Stevie Ray had classical guitar
trading I mean he was [__] great man
he could do anything he could do [__]
Texas blues and [__] Hendrix Style
[__] guitar action and he could do
Spanish guitar he could do anything so
it's not quite the same comparison
Jimmy was [__]
self-taught
pretty much
and uh was just inventing a whole new
way of playing guitars and effects and
you know he was pioneering
Stevie Ray didn't Pioneer he was
perfecting [__] that had already
happened kind of like Joe Satriani you
know something like that but so they
don't compare
again to Stevie Ray Vaughan if she might
give it to Jimi Hendrix and Stephen Ray
Vaughan was a huge Hendrix fan he would
do Hendrix covers like Voodoo Child
Perkins up
Stevie Ray knew the deal
Ben says Jenny you realize your glasses
are reflecting your lighting rig yeah I
know there's not really a lot that I can
do about that because I Gotta Wear the
glasses or I can't see
uh American Military 100 said did you
ever cover the odd and bizarre death of
the uh of Bobby Fuller yeah we talked
about that on our first mysteries of
Rock and Roll Show which was way back on
episode 69. so I didn't want to repeat
it but yeah the Bobby Fuller case is
like super super weird I think that was
even on Unsolved Mysteries now that I'm
thinking about it that might have been
where I first heard about it when I was
a kid
um but yeah so let's talk about uh Jim
Morrison
uh now he died on July 3rd 1971 also 27
years old uh same kind of thing uh in
Paris
uh found dead in the bathtub by his
girlfriend Pamela Corson uh they did not
do an autopsy because there wasn't
anything particularly suspicious about
his death uh he was in France and they
you know the French police that wasn't
the law
um so they didn't bother doing one so
the official cause of death is heart
failure
um that's what's on that's what's on the
autopsy report but it did that kind of
[__] a lot to protect the reputation of
celebrities yeah when they died of
any kind of drug overdose they kind of
left the drug overdose part out
well his heart stopped okay that's good
enough well I mean well he suffocated
okay
that's usually how they did it Zach said
are you guys gonna
what the [__] well that sounds like
popping up in front of [__] and I can't
see anything
um Zack said are you guys going to talk
about Sinead O'Connor on here by the way
she made a good uh she'd make a good
show topic I think yeah we maybe we
should maybe we should one of these days
um and I yeah High Desert said did they
ever reveal what Sinead died of yeah I
don't I did they I don't know I don't
know
yeah Ben said if your doctor signed off
on it you could bury them without an
autopsy yeah I mean technically any
death is heart failure yeah isn't it I
mean really basically is it his heart
stops you're dead but yeah
they're pretty sure they know what it is
but you know they're they're still I
think the thing about Jim Morrison was
not so much they think he was murdered
but that he didn't necessarily die in
that apartment yeah which is what we're
going to talk about I don't believe he
did either but uh well like I said it's
not it's not as out there the theory
that you know it's not as out there
because it's still he still kind of died
the same way he just didn't die like in
the way that they thought that he did he
changed the location it did yeah that's
all it was
um so yeah so as we mentioned before uh
Jim Morrison
um you know the doors actually got quite
famous quite quickly it seemed like
because they formed in what like 1965.
and then by the time like 1967 rolls
they were like world famous pretty much
but as soon as they got world famous Jim
Morrison
um they said well he'd always like
drinking yeah but the thing about Jim
Morrison was that he
wasn't real comfortable with The Rock
God thing no not at first he would sing
with his back to the audience he did at
first [__] shy as [__] he was yeah
and it's like he kind of leaned into it
after a while but then he thought and
the other members of the band thought
too that you know everything was kind of
like revolving around him and his like
good looks and his stage Antics and
stuff like that and it was kind of
getting lost like the music was kind of
getting lost and like their message was
kind of getting lost and really he
didn't want to be known as a rock star
he wanted to be known as a writer and a
poet poet um that's what he wanted to be
yeah and so I think that he was getting
to a point where he was just like sick
of all of it right yeah well
yeah
Jim was the front man he was the
ultimate front man I mean he he
commanded the attention to cameras in
the media
the girls [__] loved him but there
would have been no Jim Morrison without
[__] Ray manzaric the [__] good
the the keyboard player he was kind of
the brains behind that operation
and I think I think Ray kind of kept him
out of control and kept him focused
in other words what I'm saying is that
Morrison couldn't have gone solo
he did sometimes but he'd just go off
into poetry and [__]
yeah Ray could go solo if you want
to know he could probably get another
guy who was as good as Morrison but I
don't know hit Morrison had captured the
[__] media's attention and people's
attention already so
I'm not I'm not bashing on Morrison
Morrison was great yeah he was like
super super he's great yeah and uh but
he was a he was a man of his time uh
dealing with uh the new
the new job of being a rock star
you know there were many other rock
stars this [__] was new
and it was like I said it was the social
media of the time
so nobody knew what the roles were
and uh he was making Rules and Breaking
them
he did crazy [__] he caused [__]
riots in this [__] concerts anybody
taking their clothes take his clothes
off he'd [__] get arrested on stage
uh they they bad to get pissed off
because it was almost about him [__]
acting crazy and they wouldn't they
weren't able to [__] complete a show
sometimes because the police have shut
the [__] show down
and arrest him
so he eventually got to where he was
kind of uncontrollable
the band kind of broke up for a long
time
yeah I mean they didn't want to have to
deal with his Shenanigans yeah they want
to deal with each other too well you
didn't want to deal with him but then
they do [__] in the studio and release
[__] great signals like [__]
um Light My Fire look what's it I think
it's just called come on isn't it what
that's all
um come on baby life yeah flight my fire
yeah yeah
they actually wrote that when they were
pretty much broke up they barely think
that whole album was made when they were
broke up
well the last one they did before they
broke up was LA Woman yeah
I see I thought like my fire was like
Earth was way earlier I thought that was
one of their first ones it was one of
their later ones it was commercial as
[__] for the time
I mean it was on they were selling this
commercials too well you have to think
too that it's like they were from the
California scene yeah and California
scene at that time was pretty much like
kind of all surf music so they were kind
of coming out with this sort of like
epic grungy kind of yeah bluesy yeah
dirty it was like the Nirvana of the
time it was yeah so it was like you know
and man the doors still sound [__]
good today they're kind of Timeless yeah
um if it wasn't for that weird [__]
synthesizer that Ray played if you want
to place it I still dig that though yeah
it's got a certain sound to it just real
60s sounded
kind of crazy it sounds like an organ
almost
well yeah technically it is an organ I
guess yeah and that's a synthesizer yeah
but it's synthesizing something yeah
it's like a real primitive synthesizer
but it was real high tech in the day
Jim did call somebody he did call it
though
he said eventually there would be no
bands it would just be a box that made
music and a guy on stage sing it to it
and go yeah that's eventually what it
became they're called Industrial
VNV Nation and [__] like that well
that's at least two guys but yeah two
guys
but yeah
Jim called it but he thought that that
was going to be like a [__] great
Innovation and everybody would love it
they didn't realize how scale that is
[__] on stage live to just see a dude
on stage and recorded music coming out
of a [__] lap out of a [__] laptop
or something which like some of that's
good like just to listen to on your
phone or whatever but it's like you
don't really yeah or in the car it's
like you don't really want to like go
see that live it's like boring as [__]
right you want at least a three-piece
band that's gonna like do something yeah
like entertaining you know what I mean
but you know Morrison called it but he
didn't understand what that would
actually look like
that that would wear off that everybody
could do that yeah
so I mean the thing about it is that I
kind of feel bad for Jim Morrison
because I get
he wanted to be taken seriously I mean
he was very into he was very
intellectual he was very into poetry
very into literature and he wanted to be
taken seriously
as that
um you know and the Avenue that he kind
of got into was like doing the Rockstar
thing but then like he gets there and
he's just like well this isn't really
what I what I wanted or like what I
signed up for and it's kind of shitty
because
he was so
um attractive and because he was so
magnetic and because like you know he
had all these female fans and stuff like
that he's not gonna get taken seriously
like as an artist because and you know
and you can see all like the other guys
in the band are gonna get pissed off
about that too because they're like hey
we're the ones writing the music and
yeah [__] like that nobody gives a crap
about us
um you know what I mean they just give a
crap about him up there with his [__]
lips and everything he had a great look
he did yeah with his hair and everything
yeah it's kind of curly a little bit
kind of mid length and when he was in
good shape he had he looked like an old
Greco-Roman statue he looked like a
statue of David or something like that
you know I mean and [__] they
photographed him a lot in black and
white and put them in [__] magazines
and he looked [__] like a Greek
statue he looked great
he had a very handsome face especially
when he was thin
now some of the girls said the girls
[__] loved him all right but some of
them said he also stag because well they
were all hippies
he had a [__] pair of leather pants
that was [__] that was real thick
good quality leather pads and he wore
them constantly and he'd go on Commando
in those [__] he never washed
them and he wore them forever and they
said you could just smell him coming and
then [__] freaking dirty ass leather
pants
do you think he'd at least sponge him
out every now and then and pan supposed
to hurt [__] burning all the bacteria
I don't know leather wears pretty well
against the skin though so I don't think
they were lined
so yeah maybe but evidently you could
smell it
now that might have just been a rumored
some girls said but yeah and that might
have been just somebody that like he
rejected and then she made it I think
his girlfriend said girlfriend said
[__] complaining that it's time to
[__] take them [__] thing wash
those [__] pants damn hippies
all the Patchouli oil in the world isn't
gonna fix that yeah it was before
Patchouli yeah
no [__] Morrison would have been
bathing Patchouli if it was around at
that time probably yeah he seemed like
somebody that would totally do that
and smoking a bong
drinking [__] alcohol then trying to
a lot and trying to get into a car
but yeah he didn't have a driver's
license though
yeah he didn't have a driver's license
but he would try to drive
but yeah so
um so famously uh there was a show in
Miami in 1969 where he got accused of
indecent exposure uh for allegedly like
taking off his pants and wagging his
dick around or whatever
um even though like some people that
were there and like some people that
like manager and stuff like that said
that never that didn't happen like he
didn't do it
um but he also got in trouble for just
like swearing on stage because you could
do that back then you could get yeah
isn't that [__] up in some states yeah
well it was Florida I'm pretty sure
but um would have been like indecency or
something or vulgarity or some [__] yeah
like I was like he's been fine that's
dumb yeah
right so but yeah like so he was
actually like kind of in trouble for
that like and they were gonna he was
gonna have a trial and you know he was
out on bail but whatever
um you know he even got like the
indecent exposure charge I think he got
six months for that which is so but he
was you know free on bond while he was
um you know appealing it but whatever
Reese is getting [__] turned on he's
turning you on
I can't really see it
Ben said a guy visiting Japan got
stopped by the police and cautioned
because he'd only had a singlet on he'd
been at the beach instead of a proper
shirt
that's funny
so I just can't imagine I can't imagine
a situation where you would just say you
know [__] this on stage and like the
cops would come and I'm like don't you
guys have any like real crimes to
investigate I guess not I mean they did
they had crime back then
but yeah so
so he's in trouble for that like I said
he'd been drinking like more and more
because he was getting like real
disillusioned with the soul Rockstar
thing like the band was kind of getting
sick of his Shenanigans
um they did their last show they didn't
know it was their last show uh when they
did it obviously but um this was
December 12th of 1970 and that was in
New Orleans and
um I don't even think they finished the
show uh because Jim Morrison was just
completely shit-faced
um and he took the mic stand and just
like punched a [__] hole in the floor
of the stage or whatever and then just
like [__] stocked up so I don't even
think they finished the [__]
she got turned and she it's either he or
she got turned on Jim Morris's body okay
well like I said it's funny because the
very famous photo of him yeah you know
without the shirt that's that's all the
posters and stuff like after a while
like he absolutely would not allow that
photo to be used anymore because he just
thought it was
overshadowing like what he wanted to be
known for I guess but yeah
now there's like now everybody has that
poster in their [__] dorm room or
they used to I kind of feel like
everybody had that [__] poster yeah
unfortunately you cannot a man cannot
maintain that kind of [__] physique
once you get into your 30s [__] um
you have no choice you can't remain you
can't remain That Lean
that's the body's natural testosterone
levels start to decline you start
putting on weight so your only chat your
only way of having a nice figure is you
start the age is guys you got to pack on
muscle see it's the only way and
yeah I've looked at the sides and that's
what happened to Jim Jim got fat
but man when he was skinny he looked
[__] great
some
some skeletal
some skeletal layouts look good then
other ones don't just depends on how
tall you are and what your shoulder is
like there's certain proportions and
stuff but uh but you know I'm into
physique male and female physique you
know bodybuilding and [__] so it's not
all just about muscles there's a bunch
of different kind of looks I mean there
are fat girls that could hold fat they
look [__] great Instagram models that
man she's she's fat
looks attractive though
but it's jeans it's genetics and what
kind of skeleton that is and
where the Fat's going and can the
[__] skin support it
so there isn't just one kind of beauty
there's a lot of them you know depends
on just like flavors of ice cream it's
all ice cream it's it's all pretty good
it's all good as long as it's what it's
supposed to be you know what I mean as
long as it's not mixing ice creams that
don't mix you know
but if it's an approved flavor of ice
cream it's all right approved flavor
yeah
but Jim looked good then
High Desert said look what happened to
Axel Rose yeah last time I saw Axel Rose
man he looks like yeah I don't know man
he looks bad yeah he looks better
I don't even know I'm not a Guns and
Roses fan so I don't even know like what
the [__] that I'm imagining it's alcohol
and drugs but
Ho Ho's
[Laughter]
Maybe A Little Debbie all that couch
surfing and all that
hanging out porn star chicks and just
drinking and [__] living off of other
people and yeah
indulging yeah
so uh so yeah
so around this time like I said the band
is not doing well they played their last
gig which they didn't know was their
last gig at that point
um you know after that whole after that
gig where they didn't even finish it
um they called the rest of the tour off
and then the band is like we're going
back to LA and they're gonna finish
working on the album LA Woman which
ended up being their last album right
um so once that was done uh Jim Morrison
said I really need to get the [__] out
of here so him and his girlfriend uh
Pamela Corson moved to Paris in March of
1971. now him and her they were there
for like four months and Jim actually
seemed to be doing really well
um you know he was getting back into his
poetry like he seemed a lot happier
um you know he wasn't like people kind
of knew who he was but he didn't get
recognized in the street all the time so
it was almost like he could be like
normal
um there were photos taken of him like
in the last few days and he actually
looked good like he looked like he was
kind of healthier and he looked like
like he was having a good time and [__]
like that
um but the thing about it
as I mentioned um even though
from what I read and I don't know how
true this is but um and a lot of people
that knew him
um said that Jim Morrison was not real
into heroin
but um his girlfriend Pamela absolutely
was she was um you know and a couple of
them did call her straight up a junkie
uh and apparently Jim Morrison was not
happy about this and tried to like get
her to stop it um he didn't do it
himself but apparently he was not
successful in getting her to stop it
um they did actually you know they spent
a lot of time just walking around Paris
doing [__] like that but they went to
like a lot of nightclubs and stuff like
that so I imagine they were probably
like indulging
in a lot of their [__] and uh you know
and Jim is still drinking a lot
um so the thing about it is that on the
day before he died
he was actually hanging out in Paris
with a friend of his
um and the friend said that a few times
he had
um kind of like stumbled like while he
was like and while he was walking
upstairs he was like um like he couldn't
catch his breath you know what I mean
um and he would have like uh he would
have like a coughing fit and like some
blood would come up
so he was obviously having some health
issues despite
seeming better like being over there
so
so the thing about it um so they had
this apartment him in Pamela uh near the
Sun
and as I said they were going out to
clubs and [__] like that
um July 3rd uh what ended up happening
after Jim had spent the day with this
friend of his and he eventually went
back to his his apartment and the friend
was had to go meet some other person so
that was like the last time he ever saw
him
but Pamela apparently uh the fish
official story is that she found him
dead in the bathtub
uh in the apartment like about six in
the morning
now apparently she called for help
um she couldn't
what I heard was she didn't call the
authorities at first because she didn't
speak French so she actually called a
friend of hers who could speak French
and said can you please call the
authorities for me because I don't you
know I don't know how to explain it so
so that's what happened so they did come
there but by the time the authorities
showed up um you know he was obviously
already dead now that now the um the
First Responders they said that when
they pulled him out of the tub they said
his body was still warm but very quickly
they realized that his body was only
warm because the water had been warm
um that he looked like he had been dead
for a little while you know what I mean
um so what
uh what Pamela said happened
was that
uh they they had been at the apartment
at night and then they had gone out to
dinner they went to a movie
um and then they came back to the
apartment and listened to some music and
had some drinks and stuff like that now
apparently she did some heroin and he
did some heroin too although he didn't
usually they said now they she didn't he
didn't inject it they snorted it that's
what I heard and then Rich used to do
and another story too said that oh maybe
he thought it was cocaine but it's like
I don't but I don't buy that
yeah so um so as far as I know they
snorted it
but yeah
now she said that Jim woke up in the
middle of the night and then went to
take a bath and then she was just kind
of like still in bed and like asleep
and then when she woke up in the morning
like because she woke up and he wasn't
there and she was like what the [__] and
so she went in there and she found him
in the tub
and that I don't know if she realized he
was dead
um because like I said he was still warm
but yeah so they didn't do an autopsy
and
you know because there wasn't really
anything other than him being really
young there wasn't anything super
suspicious like it didn't look like he'd
been murdered or anything like that it
just kind of looked like an accident
like an overdose or something like that
and he like I said been having a couple
of health problems like uh prior to that
um now in recent times though and this
is something that you referred to
earlier yeah uh some people that were in
Paris at the time
uh have
have come forward and said well that's
not exactly what happened
um in 2007 there's a guy named Sam
Bennett who uh works for the New York
Times for a while but he actually used
to manage the Rock and Roll Circus Club
in Paris where uh Jim and Pamela would
go sometimes
and he came forward and said
that uh Jim Morrison actually died in
the bathroom like in a stall at that
club that's what I heard
um it wasn't a club that was like a bar
yeah yeah well you know what I mean and
it was up the street from him yeah it
was like within walking distance like
they they said they were went there all
the time they went there all the time
yeah I heard the same thing this was put
together from people that knew that
French scene French people that knew
there there was a little bar that was up
the street from where they lived
that was a [__]
let's just call it like a a hive of
junkies or something it was a bar
it sold liquor
but all the dealers hung out there
and they dealt everything it wasn't just
heroin but heroin was one of the main
things
and um
Jim and his girlfriend were regulars
there and had all their friends there
and was evidently like a cool place
there's a place where a celebrity like
Jim Morrison could go and nobody bother
him you know what I mean he was just
like part of the seat
and that they were regulars there so go
ahead yeah that that's what a lot of the
people there said yeah it was right down
the street from the apartments and they
were there all the time
um you said uh and yeah he was usually
there with her they said on that
particular night uh the guy that um
Sam Burnett I think I said uh the guy
that wrote the book he said that
um that night he actually saw Jim
Morrison meeting with two dudes who he
knew were drug dealers yeah yeah and
then around two in the morning like he
went to the bathroom yeah and then when
he didn't come back out
um the manager told a bouncer to go kick
the door down to see what was going on I
knew something was wrong and they said
that they found him unconscious in there
and they said that there was a doctor
who was like a a regular at the place
and he went and got him and said hey
come back here and check this out and
the doctor came back and said yeah he's
dead
yeah
um the guys that owned the guys that
owned the club the bouncers and
everything they all knew who Jim was
they all knew what was going on
they didn't no one ever said that the
the the the bar owners got any drug
money out of this it's just they knew
who the clientele were
so it was a safe place
for these users to go hang out and
socialize and use drugs in there
so it was it was evidently real common
to get high
but uh so this all matches up with the
story that I heard from an online source
that I was researching years back about
this how Jim Morrison actually died
so this isn't I guess I guess this story
has been around for a while it sounds
very very plausible well like I said
this came out in 2007. okay like is the
guy that allegedly that managed the club
yeah uh came out with this story in 2007
and said that he actually died in that
battle yeah our sources match up it's
the same source
also a video interview with the guy but
he said
um they found him in the bathroom the
doctor said he was already dead it said
he had some blood and foam on his nose
and the doctor said that's probably a
heroin overdose
and then apparently there was another
guy
a photographer named Patrick Chevelle
and he was at the bar as well and or he
worked at the bar he was a bartender and
he said that he helped carry Jim
Morrison up the stairs he said they
didn't call an ambulance yeah um and
they figured he was already dead and
they said
um
the drug dealers were there and the
drugs were like no no he's not dead he
just fainted uh the manager wanted to
call an ambulance but the owner of the
club said don't do that too much heat so
so yeah so they actually carried him
outside and drove him like they threw
him in the car and drove him back to his
house and then dumped him in the tub
while the girlfriend was sleeping in the
apartment
yeah now one thing that I've heard that
somebody that was talking about this and
said Well I this is what makes me not
believe it no it what I was going to say
is that
um when he was brought from the club he
was allegedly like fully dressed but
it's like when the when they came to you
know to get him out of the tub he was
naked like you would be in the bathtub
so it's like why would they have taken
the time to like take all his clothes
off and put him in the bathtub
but I don't know the way I remember the
story they
got her first
and took brought her to the club I think
and then they went to the
back to the house together
and then they took him up there and took
his clothes off and put him in the
bathtub and got the water super hot
two to hide the time of death so yeah be
nice and warm and that's the same thing
that matches up with what the ambulance
people said
when they got him out of the water he
was war but that's because the water was
warm yeah
so they detected that but it didn't
matter they just were just trying to
conceal the location of the yeah they
just didn't want to get in trouble like
nobody killed him or anything like that
it was still like the same cause of
death
it had a bunch of drug dealers in there
and the guy didn't want to lose his
business and uh there was a lot of other
people that weren't involved in this and
they didn't want to they didn't want to
cause a big snake that's France all
right
they're not that real they're not real
strict about that [__] anyway about
drugs and stuff
but uh
the
the the
did they did they tell you why he was
there
why he was where why Jim went to the
club
no okay
same Source in the interview that I saw
said that
Jim and his girlfriend had a side gig of
dealing heroin
they would sometimes go they had and to
meet dealers and you said he met two
people there and they would buy
medium size
you know quantities of heroin at a good
price
and they would sell to other people
outside the club
and that would help
kind of like fortify their income so
they could buy drugs
and also helping pay the bills because
evidently his like
his they spent a lot of money you know
what I mean so yeah he was getting
royalties and stuff but it wasn't uh he
wasn't a millionaire I don't believe at
this at this point
so they did need supplementary income at
this time
so he goes there without her
to go make the purchase
and purchases some heroin
and then goes into the bath room
to test some to see how good it was
maybe he wanted some too and he OD'd it
was strong
I don't know if he injected it or if he
snorted it it probably ejected it
because you get more bang for your buck
by injecting it
my friend Rich who I told the story
about him before he died he [__] shot
himself in the head in front of his
girlfriend
he was
a long time junkie nice guy though over
in Boston and he was another ex-army guy
and uh got off the type dude he was
older than me he was 50 when he died but
he looked at him man you think he was
30.
didn't date a woman over [__] 25 man
[__] just all these young girls
and uh
he would snort it because he said that
it was less addictive as he told me
I don't know that's true I don't because
he was addicted I mean most of the
people I've heard about that did heroin
like injected it but I have heard some
people snorting it too but I don't know
if there's that much difference in the
addiction Factor it seems like it
wouldn't be but
he said it was less addictive that you
could resist it more
but he would also
snort heroin in these parties
and then drink an entire fifth of
[__] Scotch
I don't know how to do it I don't know
how people do that and he was 50.
that's crazy
I mean even should have had to like
built up a tolerance over the years I'm
54.
and he at 50 he looked a little bit
younger than me he was kind of a thin
bill
it real well preserved
um
and the girls liked him he got [__]
in a fight with his girlfriend Soleil
who was this
really sexy mixed chick from [__]
California got into an argument
over the volume and the television while
they were watching [__] Excalibur and
he goes [__] this man I'm sick of [__]
I'm out of here and he walked into the
walk-in closet and he came out he had
his [__] Army [__] dress green
jacket on a [__] 38 Special revolver
in his head because I'm [__] sick of
you
his head off right in front of her
killed him
crazy yeah
and maybe if he'd like thought about it
for a minute he wouldn't have done that
yeah
that's the thing
just out of the blue yeah
but the thing about it another thing
that came out after this was that
um you know Mary and faithful uh very
famous she said that she thought that
her boyfriend at the time was the one
who sold Jim Morrison the heroine that
killed him
like she didn't think he did it on
purpose obviously what was his story was
a different story there well no no it's
the same story it's just like in the
club but she's just saying that she's
pretty sure that her boyfriend was the
one that saw okay him the drugs that
killed him um and her quote was I'm sure
it was an accident the smack was too
strong yeah and he died that's what she
said so I don't know if that's true or
not but she's saying this still made
matches up with what I heard right right
um but like I said they didn't do an
autopsy so they don't know but most
people kind of know uh there's also
rumors going around I don't believe
these either that uh Jim Morrison like
faked his own death no but I I don't
believe that's the case no he's he's
dead and and he's buried in the uh
perilous Cemetery in Paris alongside a
lot of his literary Heroes so I'm sure
that probably would have made him happy
all right so we got a couple more little
short ones before like short-ish ones
now this one there's not a lot of
information about this one but I thought
this was interesting so I wanted to kind
of like add this one
so this happened in 1987 and this was
Gary Driscoll now Gary Driscoll might
not be
um like a household name obviously the
way Jim Jimi Hendrix and Jim Morrison
are but he was like an r b style drummer
who was actually in a bunch of bands uh
from like starting in the 1960s now he
first got into the you'll appreciate
this I think
but he joined a band called the prophets
in June 1965 with guess who Ronnie James
Dio yeah uh yeah a lot of cancer not too
long ago right [__] was five
foot three seven like he was six foot
four I'm a very good sing yeah
but yeah so that's how he started out
like he was in a band with Ronnie James
Dio
um and then that band eventually became
the electric elves then they were called
The Elves and then there was called elf
yeah in 1969. yeah because Ronnie looked
like a [__] elf probably yeah a
little
Italian looking out
actually made Three Studio albums which
were produced by Roger Glover from Deep
Purple who was the guy that um yeah
discovered them yeah now uh elf broke up
in 1975 and
um they actually like Gary Driscoll
Ronnie James Dio and a couple other
people they got recruited by Richie
Blackmore yeah and like formed rainbow
yeah
now Driscoll as far as I know only
played on Rainbow's first album And The
Story Goes that Richie Blackmore
fired him because they like didn't like
his style of drumming which was like two
r b there's actually a very funny clip
it's about eight or nine minutes long on
YouTube of Richie Blackmore talking
about Gary Driscoll
and he's actually very even though he
they fired him
um after the first album
um he's actually very complimentary of
him and like the way he was talking
about him is very um it's kind of like a
loving tribute because apparently Gary
Driscoll they said he was very clumsy
like he was always like knocking his
drunk kid over and it's like so it's
very very funny stories that he has
about this poor guy
but yeah so he was in he was on the
first uh rainbow album
now um he got like later on he played in
um a band called Dakota which is kind of
the name of Marquette uh and also he
started a band called Bible black
um with uh duck McDonald who would be in
blue cheer later on
um they did a couple other albums as
well so after that Gary Driscoll
basically like became a session musician
and then also had to get a day job so he
wasn't like super super famous
but the thing about Gary Driscoll
was in a 1987 on June 8th he was
actually found murdered in Ithaca New
York
and his murder is still unsolved there's
not a huge amount of details about it
but there is evidence to suggest that
the murder was carried out by more than
one person
um the one suspect that they had like
actually fled the country uh so they and
has never been named but there are also
rumors that the killing was maybe drug
related but the biggest rumor is that
Driscoll that the murder was either like
occult related or that he was
dismembered or that he was partially
flayed
uh it was one thing that I saw like they
just I guess they just found him in his
apartment or whatever because the reason
why they're saying this
Ronnie James Dio
rainbow
elf those bands they hung out with
other [__] bands that kind of had a
mystical quality to them yeah when
someone say satanic they weren't satanic
though you go back and you look at those
lyrics today they're fantasy lyrics
uh they they mentioned magic and
cardinal points and [__] but there's
nothing really negative about it so I
could see how
conspiracy theorists will jump in and
say oh it's a cult you know
well especially because the murder was
never solved yeah but um
if you listen to the work of these bads
and then Ronnie later on ended up being
in Black Sabbath and then he went solo
and Dio [__] great band grew up
listening to that
they were in a way quite positive
a lot of the messaging um
it was a cult in a in the way
Lord of the Rings is a cult you know
what I mean yeah they did kind of play
into that but it was just
stage you know
Irani was a great guy Ronnie was real
friendly everybody loved him
yeah but uh I didn't know about this
murder
there's not a lot of information about
it which I was I was kind of frustrated
because I was looking for stuff to talk
about and I kind of came across this
like on some blog post somewhere I'm
like wow that's weird yeah and so like
then I went like looking for all this
other information and there really isn't
much yeah I've never heard of it so
apparently like I look for all newspaper
reports and stuff like that and it's
like there's hardly any details what was
the cause of death
that's another thing like they couldn't
really I mean I'm assuming
I'm assuming stabbed but I don't know I
don't know though
I don't know though probably I guarantee
you it was not occult related it was
probably not because that's usually
exaggerated like I'm not saying that
never happens it does occasionally but
most of the time not what the deal was
here most probably something really
mundane
like a fight over a woman maybe
somebody's girlfriend was taking this
taking a like into this guy and a
boyfriend [__] got into an argument
the next thing you know it built up to a
fight you got dude got stabbed and died
it might have been something just that
dumb
because most of the time it's something
dumb well yeah when dudes fight it's
almost yeah
[Laughter]
that's just how that's how they were
done for that dude well now thank you I
guess not well no I'm just saying but
yeah I'm not saying that it's dumb that
he died I'm just saying that it was a
dumb reason it's usually it's something
dumb that builds up it does this [__]
big thing you know people need to calm
down yeah that's all I have to say don't
be partially flaying people just over
stupid [__] like that yeah it's not
worth it because it did not work he was
partially afraid we'd know about it
that's what I mean it's like I kept
seeing that come up on stuff and I'm
just kind of like I want to see the
police report on this but I couldn't
find it I couldn't find it but it's just
oh we're sure that this happened
yeah he's dead so it's not alleged now
my what they might be but I don't know
exactly like I don't know exactly what
the crime scene looked like because
right you don't know he was stabbed
right yeah I'm just speculating I'm just
speculating it might have been something
just as simple as dude was beaten to
death punched a couple maybe because it
fell down hit his head and died
that could happen it might you know what
I mean and then a big Legend is born
around it not enough we don't have
enough evidence with this that's what
I'm saying I just wanted to mention that
one because I kind of feel like a lot of
people don't yeah mention it and I just
came across it and I was just like what
and said but then I couldn't find
anything else early about it so it's
like and it happened a while back it was
in 87. all right so the last one I want
to talk about because I don't think I
think that I was going to talk about
this on the first mysteries of rock and
roll show we did but I don't think I had
time because I didn't put it in the
description so if I'm repeating myself
forgive me but I do want to talk about
because this is kind of weird uh The
Disappearance of Richie Edwards from the
Manic Street Preachers and this happened
in 1995. I never heard of these guys so
um they're actually quite a good band
um I they formed like I believe in the
late 80s
uh and got real big in the 90s
I remember seeing them on 120 minutes
and stuff like that and I always thought
I well I kind of knew a lot about them
too because they're Welsh and they came
from Blackwood which is where my
ex-husband's grandmother lived so I've
actually been to Blackwood many times
it's a very very small like uh used to
be a mining town
so um so yeah so Richie Edwards was
actually the uh Lyricist for the Manic
Street creatures also they call him the
Rhythm guitarist although he couldn't
really play guitar he was mostly just
The Lyricist guy I mean they did have
him like up on stage but as far as I
know they didn't turn his guitar on they
just kind of had him up there miming but
he was the one that wrote the words and
because his words were so amazing
a few part of the band he originally
started out as their driver I think uh
but then when they figured out when they
saw like some of his lyrics and stuff
like that they're like oh [__] you need
to be in this [__] band so the thing
about it was that like I said they were
from this town called Blackwood which in
Wales and I've been there uh many times
they still live over there back in the
90s and uh it's a very very small town
it used to be a big Coal Mine there
where everybody worked and then it
closed in the 80s certainly was
unemployed so it's it's very very small
and um these guys you know growing up in
the 80s and 90s in this very tiny town
you know there was nothing for them to
do and it's just like they were kind of
into
you know more alternative [__] they were
kind of um
you know they weren't like the super
masculine hanging down at the pub and
watching football and all that kind of
rugby or whatever the [__]
um you know so they got beat up a lot
and [__] like that so they just kind of
and but they were real into they're very
very intellectual they were very into
um you know literature and politics and
all that kind of stuff and they put all
of that into their music so like a lot
of you know alternative kids of the 90s
like really got into them and they
actually got quite famous probably more
in the UK than here but I knew of them
just from watching like 120 minutes and
stuff now I don't know if you guys know
but Richie Edwards uh disappeared in
February 1995 and has not been seen
since
um now he has been legally declared dead
as of 2008 so that his family could uh
you know sort out his Affairs and things
like that but uh his disappearance has
never been solved and there have been
some theories about what happened to him
now um one of the things that he's best
known it now the thing about Richie
Edwards is that
um one of the things he was best known
for other than being like an awesome
Lyricist was that he was
um very open about his depression and
about his self-harm one of the most
famous incidents and this has pretty
much always brought up if you talk about
the Manic Street Preachers is that in
there was an interview with a guy from
uh the nme whose name was Steve lamack
and Steve Lemak was kind of giving them
[__] about being posers
um or plastic punks or whatever they
used to call them it's a Green Day
plastic box yeah and uh and [__] like
that so uh so there I gotta say the
Green Day got the [__] thumbs up they
got the go-ahead by [__] uh John lyde
Johnny Rotten said they were a great
band
I saw Green Day at a college
in Gainesville before they got famous
because I had one of their old albums
like before they got real big and that
album was actually quite good yeah
jobline was impressed he thought they
were a great band I mean I'm not super
into pop punk but I thought they were
good I didn't like their later [__] but
um because it went to commercial but
their their early [__] was yeah it was
actually quite good that's what he's
talking about it was actually quite good
he said they sounded great in that he
goes yeah they're
he's like they're pop and then like
Facebook he says they sound really good
though he says I like them so yeah well
like I said I had their like one of
their it was either their first album
was that I guess their first album I
can't even remember what it's called now
but it was like before they got famous
and it's actually quite good I actually
quite liked it and I actually saw them
like on a college campus like before
they got famous too I used to like the
White Stripes too
yeah the White Stripes are actually
quite good yeah yeah quite good
but yeah so um so yeah so so they got
accused of being it's like oh I don't
really believe you guys are just posers
you don't really believe all this [__]
that you say in your songs and it's like
you're not that deep and all this other
kind of [__] every Interpol yeah they
were good too yeah I like that I gotta
go back and revisit Interpol
yeah um but yeah around that time yeah
but so um so yeah so this journalist the
nme guy um he just kept [__] with
them and kind of just saying it's like
are you you guys aren't for real you
guys aren't for real so apparently
Richie Edwards is like hey come back
here like backstage or whatever into
this back room for a minute and he took
a razor blade that he had from somewhere
and carved for real in his arm like
quite deeply like so deeply that he
needed 18 stitches damn
um just to show that he was serious
because he was mad that he wasn't being
taken seriously and apparently like the
journalist just sitting there going oh
[__] like you know what I mean like and
it was this big deal and they actually
liked the enemy like had they took all
these pictures of it
and there was this big because I was
listening to a documentary about it and
they had some um audio of like all the
people that worked at the enemy like
arguing over whether they should print
the photos or not because they were so
gross right like they were so disgusting
because I mean he really [__] went in
there he wasn't [__] around and um
they eventually did print them
and they're pretty nasty but uh but yeah
so that was kind of like a big so but he
was very open about his self-harm and
this was kind of like a double-edged
sword I guess because I think in the 90s
like nobody was really like nowadays
everybody knows about that
um but back in the 90s it wasn't really
talked about all that much and I think
he was kind of the first sort of high
profile person to talk about that openly
and so like I think a lot of fans sort
of related to that on the other hand
um the way he talked about it because he
was quite intelligent and quite
articulate and the way he talked about
it almost sounded like he was justifying
a little bit and when he says it it
sounds kind of reasonable because he's
like look where I grew up you know dudes
would get mad and they would like punch
their wives or whatever and it's just
kind of like I would rather like if I
get mad and I have to do violence I
would rather not do it against like an
innocent person like take it out on
somebody else I'll just take it out on
myself which like I said I see where
he's coming from you know what I mean
like it's not great because
you know you say that to like
impressionable teenagers that are like
listening to your music they're like oh
absolutely I'm gonna cut myself up too
but you know what I mean
um but I get where he's coming from
so obviously he had
some mental health issues but he was
like quite open with them but everyone
kind of knew about that so that was one
thing that they were uh kind of known
for and he'd actually
um spent time at The Priory clinic in
London although according to his
bandmates it didn't really he was in
there for a while but it didn't really
seem to help him
in November of 1994 he actually went out
on tour with the Manic Street Preachers
and they were actually on the cusp of um
because they got quite big like I said
probably in the U in the UK and they
were going to uh tour the U.S
uh in so then they were gonna leave like
on January like last day of January or
first day of February of 1995 they were
actually going to leave uh to go to the
to come to the U.S to do a big tour
which reminded me very strongly of Ian
Curtis from Joy Division who killed
himself
um like right before Joy Division was
going to come to the US for their first
time in tour and like he didn't want to
I don't that wasn't the only reason he
did it but he just didn't want to go
another unspeakable loss who knows what
Joy Division would have become [__]
23 years old he was wrote lyrics like an
old man like a wise old man just just
World weary [__]
if you've never heard Joy Division get a
Joy Division album called closer and go
listen to that she has a white and it's
got funerary statues on the front of it
it's [__] damn I love that yeah and
it's just an eerie album
really good this reminds me of winter
time in Boston for some reason yeah it
is a very wintery [__] feeling yeah
it's very it sounds very cold Hollow and
echoey yeah
I read somewhere I don't remember where
I read this I read this was like years
and years ago they said it's one of
those
um albums that is really good to listen
to with no other sensory stimuli yeah
um so I tried it one time so it's like
so I blacked out all the windows and
like to just turned off all the other
sound and everything like that and I was
like wow it was like it's really
it's an experience like when nothing
else is distracting you from it this
dude's only 23 minutes right he's
writing lyrics like something like a
[__] due to 63 would write yeah who's
been through a lot of [__] which is
crazy because everybody that you know
the the dudes in the band was obviously
that went on to become like you know
Barney and uh and hooky and them that
went on to become New Order
um they were just like he was just like
a regular bloke yeah you know
he wasn't like all dudes or anything
like that but he did yeah good imagery
in him yeah
but yeah so so I kind of felt like this
was a similar kind of situation because
that was the same thing that Ian Curtis
did he and Curtis uh hanged himself
actually in 1980.
um but Richie Edwards so they were going
to it was literally the day before like
the day that they were supposed to fly
to the U.S right
um
so
and Richie Edwards also was 27 at the
time that he disappeared
so on February 1st 1985 he was supposed
to show up at the airport like along
with other band members because they
were in Flight of the U.S for the tour
um Richie Edwards however did not show
up
so they didn't think too much about it
at the time they're just like oh well
maybe he just overslept or whatever it's
like we're gonna fly and maybe he'll
come later
um however when they started like kind
of asking around like nobody seems to
know where Richie Edwards is
um you know they're like you know maybe
he'll come the next day but he didn't
show up so then everybody kind of got
worried and then they started doing an
investigation
now when they started looking into it
they discovered
that Richie Edwards uh they looked into
his bank records
and it showed that he had been
withdrawing 200 pounds every day from
his bank account in the two weeks
leading up to the day of his
disappearance now at that time in 1995
200 pounds was the maximum you could
take out of an ATM like in a day
so he was doing that every day now they
don't really know if that was because he
was getting cash to come to the United
States like he was saving it up or if he
was gonna buy drugs with it or they
didn't know but they just thought that
was really weird that he'd spent like
the two weeks after The Disappearance
taking out 200 pounds a day what was he
cleaning his account out um I don't know
how much was it was in his account at
the time they said that um by the time
of his disappearance he would have had
um at that time 2 800 pounds which in
today's American currency would be about
seven thousand dollars
so that's how much he would have had
when he disappeared
now so they didn't know where he was the
last confirmed sighting of him
apparently was when he checked out of
the hotel at 7am
on the morning of February 1st like he
was supposed to check out of the hotel
and then go to the airport they were
supposed to come over here
now in the hotel room though like he
checked out of the hotel but in this
hotel room he left
a packed suitcase behind he left it in
it
he did take his wallet and his passport
and other stuff
but after that
um they're not sure if he was ever seen
again now there was a couple of
sightings of him allegedly
in the days following the disappearance
apparently there was one guy who was a
fan
and he uh actually didn't know that
Richie Edwards had been reported missing
he said that he saw Richie Edwards at
the bus station in Newport which I've
been to many many times
in Wales
um so the two of them like had a
conversation like because apparently
they had a mutual a girl they both knew
or something like that so they were both
like asking about her and this fan
apparently didn't note anything unusual
like didn't see any unusual behavior or
anything like that no one's sure if this
is true or anything if the dude just
made it up or whatever but that was like
a a sighting
on the 7th of February which was about a
week after his disappearance a taxi
driver in Newport
um he kind of went to the authorities
and said that he had picked up someone
that he was pretty sure was Richie
Edwards and he drove him around Newport
and then he drove him past his old house
like where he grew up in Blackwood in
Wales where he would have grown a rich
group yeah right
um the driver also said that the
passenger asked if he could lie down in
the back seat almost like he didn't want
anyone to see him
so he and he thought he was acting a
little bit weird
um so he said the the passenger the taxi
driver believed that this was Richie
Edwards he left him at the Severn view
service station right by the Severn
Bridge which if you don't know is the
bridge that connects uh Wales and
England
uh or South Wales and the south of
England obviously I've driven over it
many times uh so there's that so he left
him there he said the guy paid um 68
pounds in cash which was the fair
and that's where he left him
now uh they thought that his that he had
this car at this service station here
now February 14th which was about two
weeks after he disappeared
um they you know they gave his car a
parking ticket and then a few days after
that uh they designated the car as being
abandoned because obviously nobody come
back to get it so the investigators went
in there to look in it and when they
looked in his car uh it appeared as
though someone had been living in there
uh they found some clothes they found
some recent photos of Richie Edwards
family they found like food wrappers and
things like that so it looked like
somebody had been living in it for
several days
um so that so that's about they they're
not really sure
what happened to him
after this point if indeed all of these
sightings were him
now the overarching theory is that he
probably
whether he was alive for a week or
something like that but he had parked
his car right here by the Severn bridge
and then he jumped off the Severn bridge
now the Severn bridge is you know sadly
quite known as a popular suicide spot
because it's very high like off the
water
um so some people now I will note that
his body has never been found
um and the Severn River was uh was
searched quite extensively but uh I will
note too that the Severn River uh I
believe does go into the sea at some
point so if you know and it does have
very strong currents that River so he
may have been washed out to see hence
why they never found his body that
sounds plausible to me
um however uh there are there are there
is a contingent of people that think
that Richie Edwards uh faked his death
um because there were like a couple
reasons for that one uh some people
thought that they saw him later on like
the recitings of him in Israel and some
people thought that he had like met this
girl there was like some evidence he had
met this girl in Israel and he was
talking about going there to meet her
and he was kind of sick of the rock star
life and bloody blah
uh so maybe that had happened and also
there was he had like left
books uh first of like he his favorite
movie was Eddie and the Cruisers which
if you've never seen Eddie the Cruisers
like from the 80s is kind of about a guy
that like fakes his own death you know
so there's that and he also left a book
for a friend uh in which the character
like fake their own death so some people
kind of think maybe he did that
um red-haired but yeah but it's like he
hasn't turned up in all of the times
since then now the rest of the band
members
there have been people
that have committed suicide
and then told left evidence behind
saying that they faked their death or
were abducted by UFOs and [__]
like for instance there was I think it
was a Spanish guy or he might have been
Central American
he's in a Cessna airplane calling the
tower over water reporting a UFO and he
says it's coming it's coming to get me
and then he never he was never seen from
him again
I think they found the plane it was just
crashed empty plane in the water
but what he did is kill himself he
killed himself
and he didn't want his parents to know
and he killed himself I think
yeah I mean that could be so there are
some people that kill themselves and
then they try to want to hide the fact
that they're doing it out of some kind
of shame or
trying to
give their parents hope that they're
still alive somehow somewhere to have a
deal
which I think is actually kind of cruel
if you're gonna [__] kill yourself
let everybody know yeah I mean it's it's
sucky because it's like they're dead but
it's like at least they're I think it's
kind of worse yeah if the person's just
missing and you never figured out what
happened to them that that must be
horrible leaving them hanging
um this guy here it sounds like he was
thinking about it for a long time
and then uh hesitated to pull the
trigger right away wandered around for a
few weeks spending his money
and then did it I think he's dead it
might have been yeah and I and honestly
like I said they actually did legally
declare him dead in 2008 because they
haven't found hiding her hair of them
since then
but um give it a turned up by now you
would think because he would have gotten
sick of hiding or
had to come back for money and run out
of money type of deal and he only had
what was the equivalent of six thousand
dollars you'll blow through that quick
no he's dead that was just going away
party
yeah maybe I'm kind of that's what I'm
leaning towards yeah and he went by his
the house where he grew up he wanted to
see it one last time
um I thought this was actually kind of
Amazing Life review
the other
um three members of The Magic Tree
pictures because they're I think they're
still around I'm not really sure but
they you know they got a new um
did they get a new Lyricist I'm not
really sure but um they actually for a
long time they still might do this
whenever they do a show they always put
like a an extra microphone at their [__]
like as a sign of respect like for him
and for a long time I don't know if they
still do this but they did this for many
years after his disappearance they
actually still put 25 of all their
royalties into his bank account in case
he ever came back
which I thought was kind of nice
um apparently and I was watching this
one uh this very long uh it was just
this girl like this goth girl woman she
was like 37 and she was a huge fan she's
British and she was a big fan of Manic
Street creatures and she did like an
hour hour and a half long uh thing about
Richie Edwards and she was talking about
him and she said I don't know if you
guys remember this like it was kind of a
big thing in the UK but when the
Millennium came like when it was New
Year's Eve like on 2000 the Manic Street
Preachers did a huge show like um and
everybody it's like pretty much she's
like pretty much everybody in the UK
like was watching that [__] because it
was like this big event
and she's like in a lot of the fans you
know in the early days of the internet
they're all in the Usenet forums and
stuff like that and they were saying oh
you know Richie's gonna come back like
on the Millennium because he'd only been
gone for five years at that point and
they were all just like waiting for that
to happen but obviously it didn't happen
I never heard of this story it's a good
story yeah but it's it's really sad
because he seemed like a very troubled
individual and the thing about it is
that even though he said a lot of times
that you know he would never kill
himself
um because I think one of the quotes and
I'm kind of paraphrasing what he said
but he said something like
um
you know I'm a strong person like I can
handle pain so it's like it never really
crossed his mind like to kill himself
but that doesn't mean I mean he was he
had a lot of mental problems he was you
know very open about his depression he
was very open about his self-harm so I
don't think it's really that much of a
stretch and you said that he was getting
ready for a tour yeah like I said they
were supposed to fly out that morning
they were coming to the U.S okay they
were doing a US tour yeah so that was
that the first U.S tour I believe it
might have been I'm not entirely sure
though he was getting performance
anxiety maybe well like I said they were
massive in the UK I had heard of them
but they obviously weren't as massive
over here as they were yeah depression
and all kinds of mental problems he was
doubting himself thinking that he wasn't
as good as he really was that he didn't
deserve any of this
that he was an imposter
that's yeah that's pretty common he
couldn't go through with it that's
pretty common he's afraid he wouldn't be
good enough
which is sad this kind of stuff just
make me so sad yeah that well that's
what happened to Ian I think
mostly got from Joy Division yeah and
well I mean he had a lot of it wasn't
just like the American tour that was
definitely their first American
tourister but
um he had just like his wife had just
had a baby
he was
um
he had real bad epilepsy which was not
very well managed uh with the medication
he was on
um he was also allegedly having an
affair
um and that was a whole issue
and he was feeling bad about that
because like I said his wife just having
the baby and all of that so it was a
kind of a big [__] and I just
think he couldn't take it anymore too
much uh too much stress it was just too
much
um and like I said he was young he was
only 23. well Richie Edwards was only
27.
and it's a moment of weakness well the
thing about it is that a lot of times I
mean think about it when you're 23 27
whatever it's like that's still very
young and well think about what would
have happened if you had suddenly become
super famous
it's really and and especially if you
become super famous and you're not real
mentally stable before that and then
suddenly like everybody's looking at you
and everybody like has expectations of
you right and it's just like I that can
[__] you up I understand that yeah I
understand that it's like it's not too
much pressure it is especially back in
those days it was kind of like internet
was weak it was still kind of the normal
media everybody's being funneled into a
very small so you were going to have
millions and millions of people watching
you it's a lot of pressure
so and I and I and I don't blame people
at all for not being able to handle that
I don't think most people could handle
it without I just I'm not saying most
people would off themselves but I'm
saying most people would probably like
have to find some [__] unhealthy way
to deal with that one of the members of
Duran Duran said [__] it I'm too famous
I'm out of here remember that got
married to that damn supermodel and
vanished
yeah another thing they're doing the Rio
tour wouldn't it
now are you talking about Roger he was
one of the first ones to leave he was
yeah but he's still he stuck around
because he was in Arcadia he came back
no no no no there was one guy
who left
right after they got famous like a year
or so oh famous oh you're talking about
somebody else yeah he got married he
just left I don't even know the guy's
name he had he had black black curly
hair
was he a drummer no
well like I said I know that Roger who
was the drummer yeah was not real into
the whole Fame thing that might have
been him but like I said he came back
huh yeah yeah well he was around until
Arcadia and then like after they did
Arcadia and then when they were gonna do
notorious yeah Roger left all right
um you know and we might be thinking of
the same guy yeah but he just uh married
some super fun
model chick he had money well I think
Roger went and like lived on a farm or
something yeah they had money they
didn't have to work anymore
but yeah because well the thing about it
is like if you get Super Famous and you
make like millions of dollars it's like
why put yourself through all of that
yeah you don't have to go on tour you
don't have to if you don't want to if
you have money for the rest of your life
I mean you know as long as you're not
like spending it all in hookers and blow
I mean if you just go and live on a farm
or something if that's what you want to
do yeah it's like you'd probably be set
for the rest they come over here see a
and it's a lot cheaper
I was listening to some British guys
today online just amazed
that for only a few hundred thousand
dollars you could get basically a damn
palatial mansion out in the middle of
Wyoming or something
but if you want to live if you want to
live out here but a lot of rich people
buy these huge houses out in the middle
of nowhere
and they have their own little airfields
in that area that they fly in well yeah
I mean if you're rich you're rich if you
can live in the middle of nowhere and
it's not like a big deal because they
don't work there
right and like I said you have a little
private plane you can leave if you want
yeah they're just hiding out you're not
like stuck right you know this this
house was almost 475
000 big two two-story house it's five
bedrooms though five bedrooms and
with this amount of money out in the
middle of nowhere and [__]
Mississippi would buy a [__] huge
mansion a huge mansion
but you couldn't
you couldn't afford that Miss in
Mississippi working a job in Mississippi
no there are no jobs that could support
that
a dollar goes a long way out there but
there isn't very many ways to make a
dollar funerals yeah if you already have
money if you already have a lot of money
and you want to live out in Illinois
basically then you're in luck yeah
because there's any number of places
where you can get a [__] Mansion yeah
in the middle of nowhere I was talking
about hardly anything talking to regular
regular on the show connivot Salon a
friend of mine a lot he's he's in here
sometimes lives in Tijuana Mexico
he was just telling me the prices of
what you can get in Mexico for this you
get a palace in Mexico for this I mean
I'm showing pictures and they're just
beautiful yeah
yeah Americans have a weird concept of
what [__] because I grew up in South
America if you guys don't know if you're
new to the show I grew up in Brazil
[__] um but Americans have a weird
concept of Mexico they hear about these
cartels God it must be hell everybody
running and they're all going across the
border no man [__] Mexico's a [__]
Paradise every time it's really funny
because every time well not every time
but a lot of times when you see movies
where like they go to Mexico or
something it all looks like the same
[__] set that's like this old junkie
yeah town I feel like it's up it's like
it's like yeah maybe a little bit of
Mexico looks like half of it Mexico
City's [__] got a huge Cloud scene
it's got huge [__] skyrises and
[__] it's just kind of like you know
when we were growing up in the 80s yeah
and every time something was set in
quote unquote Africa yeah it always
looked like [__] tribal like yeah and
I'm just like they have like cities
there yeah Nigeria is looking quite good
now yeah if you showed somebody like a
[__] picture yeah of of that it's
like they just be it's like yeah it's
Africa you know what I mean it's just
like there's this like American European
Supremacy the idea that everywhere
outside of our world is the hell like I
was living in Brazil I tell people I
live in Brazil you know back in the 80s
they were like they were like damn like
I was living in a Hut in Africa or some
[__] like that right Brazil was [__]
gorgeous man it was like a living Duran
Duran video
[__] hell yeah it's just really funny
well a lot of Americans don't travel
only outside of the country oh [__]
South America's like that [__]
Uruguay Paraguay Chile Argentina [__]
they're great man I'd like to go to
Colombia yeah Colombia's got problems
Colombia is fun man [__]
oh [__] everybody knows when they
said they have a have a great time
[__] the people are super nice
beautiful a lot of Americans move there
yeah
and if you have any if
if you have just kind of like a regular
amount of money here for America you can
go there and you just [__] that's
that's why a lot of Americans move there
yeah because it's it's a high standard
of living for like not a lot of money
and the food is fast a lot of people
retire there the food is fantastic great
meat like Central America like a lot of
countries in the central fruit and
vegetables man it's Paradise
that's why after World War II all the
dev Germans all the Nazis [__] ran
down there to [__] if it wasn't hot
I'd probably consider it because it's
like I don't I don't really want to
retire somewhere even here it's not hot
it's on the other side of the Equator if
you go I know but Brazil's the same it's
just reversed the seasons are reversed
it's on the other side of the equation I
know but still yeah but no that would be
weird that would take some getting used
to I know Argentina's like
Europe you know it's yeah
Antarctica is near there
you know yeah
it's just funny well I think I've told
this story before but my
um my stepdad's mom when I she's dead
now but I mean when we were going back
and forth when I was going back and
forth to the UK all the time
she actually asked me one time and this
was like in the 2000s
if they had VCRs over there yeah
crazy
Mexico's got a fantastic Godsey and I
was like the and the weird thing about
that was that I don't know if like a lot
of Americans know but like when I was
going back and forth to the UK in the
90s the UK was actually like
technologically was quite a bit ahead of
the us at the time
um when I was over there in the 90s like
way more people had cell phones and they
were like cell phone shops like ever
like way before it was ubiquitous in the
US way before like I noticed that like a
lot more people had them so I moved to
Brazil like in uh 83.
it's a kid with my parents
and the food in Brazil and I was I moved
there from California from the Los
Angeles area and the food was much
better in Brazil beautiful beef
fantastic pork shahaskaria which is like
[__] Brazilian barbecue [__]
it's like something so Gauchos make it
like like they have nothing the Papas
yeah uh man beautiful [__] man and and
Americans didn't know anything about
that nah of course not no
the fruits and the vegetables they're
far superior to what we have here
I've often dreamed of just like eating
my way around the entire world
and by the time I got back I would weigh
600 pounds
because of all of the yummy food that
I'd be eating because because I love I
watch all those shows like where there's
like people go to all these other
countries and they eat all the street
food and stuff and just like oh I wish
that was my job yeah like just going all
these countries and just eating all the
food I can totally Central South
Americans have [__] great booze they
make gray booze so they're all kind of
beers wines tequila in in Mexico they
probably have that [__] in Nicaragua and
the other parts of Central America too
the perhaps similar stuff uh Brazil was
they had piga which is stuck in the pure
sugar cane alcohol
and it had this weird [__] like
focapalista which is like kind of like
Grand Marnier in a way [__] but like
Rod gut Grand Marnier it's just kind of
like a whiskey flavored liqueur
uh then they had all kinds of Spanish
[__] like shinzano they had all that
they had
lots of beer good beer too uh some of
the beers kind of had German names
because he had German immigration you
have Irish immigration all throughout
South America people don't realize that
but it's like a yeah all the Irish
people didn't come here they didn't come
they went other places
Brazil Brazil Brazil has a [__] ton of
mix in it mchenry's McDowell's there's
lots of them
and I think I've heard that uh Ireland
or excuse me I've heard that uh Chile
was like that also like Ralph Santiago
uh Pinochet is [__] top generals and
all his men and his troops and he liked
he built a big Monument to Chilean
Chilean Irish immigrants that were there
for Generations that [__] uh [__]
help build the nation and [__] during
their Civil War there's
you know America likes to think of
itself as or North America the United
States likes to think of itself as
unique art our history is very similar
to Brazil and Argentina real similar and
not too different from and very
intertwined with Mexico
and America's relationships been going
on for [__] centuries
and Texas
was a joint business venture between
American families and Mexican families
about the cattle industry this is a
fantastic history here
people forgotten it that sounds like
another show yeah you do like a whole
you gotta do a history of [__] Texas
a Texas country I'm fascinated by
history so it's like we could do like a
whole history series Conan was a Texican
I'm just making my own Conan was a test
more work for myself
Howard
Howard the writer of [__] Conan
describes a Conan
that is Germanic Mexican
he's blue uh dark hair big swarthy
he's talking about German texicans
Conan was a Texan
that's what it is yeah
okay so a lot of people don't know don't
know the history I'll mention
well as we always like to point out
history is always a lot more complex
than people remember yeah and Arnold's
youngest son is half Mexican he looks
just like uh he looks just like Arnold
and he's a bodybuilder now I forgot what
his name is Pena
Pena is his last name
but that's Arnold Schwarzenegger's
youngest son
I've been watching his uh bodybuilding
progress if you ever wanted to make
another Conan movie you get him Joseph
Pena is his name I believe I believe his
opinion Joseph he looks just like
[__] Arnold a slightly Mexican Arnold
and that's that's how [__] Robert E
Howard is
the yeah do the trilogy like they should
yeah then that's who they should have to
do it any Act
I don't know I've Just Seen Him Live yes
we'll find out he looks like a
20-something year old Arnold schwarzen I
guess you could argue that Arnold
Schwarzenegger couldn't really act
either she's good enough yeah he wasn't
yeah he was adequate he was a performer
right he's more of a performer than an
actor right although when he did Maggie
he actually acted in that
yeah I would and and actually if anybody
wants to see like Arnold Schwarzenegger
actually like acting like I recommend
Maggie and it's a zombie movie too but
not but not like a cliched zombie movie
it's actually like really good
actually I like that movie a lot Zach
says oh my God it's going to be almost
100 degrees tomorrow kill me
um yeah I mean we live in Florida I I
feel your pain but you know what it
wasn't that bad today I think it was
only in the 90s because like I went out
and sat in my car at lunch and I was
like wow I don't feel like dying
necessarily it's just there's a slight
breeze there's air at least but you know
um
yeah
Tammy says history of Irish slaves yeah
wait somebody asked me to do
um
there was a book called The Lost German
slave girl which actually I read several
years ago and they have read it as well
and so they recommended me do a show
about that
um and that kind of as far as I remember
it's been a while since I've read it but
um they did kind of go into the whole
like Irish indentured servitude like a
lot of the Europeans that came over here
like and went into indentured servitude
so they kind of went into that too which
was actually like pretty interesting
so yeah that might make an interesting
show as well
um
yeah Zach says Mexico City is gorgeous
and South Africa is really beautiful too
yeah it's I mean I'm sure that's it's
not the same as it used to be but it's
just like funny because I just remember
back in the 80s like everybody
every time you brought up Mexico or
Africa or something like that like
people had definite
um stereotypes about that that were
really like
either like wildly out of date or just
complete fictions like they didn't look
anything like like we just got that from
like old movies or something I guess but
it's like it just didn't look like that
at all and it's just like I I couldn't
even believe
my my stepdad's Mom asking me if they
had VCRs
in the UK
in the 2000s
you know I was just like
what a weird question it's like I'm not
really sure what she was imagining what
that country looked like I'm like they
got all the same [__] we got and
actually they got better [__] than we
got so it's like I'm not really sure
what your deal is it was just like
really funny the United States is
advantages we have access to a lot of
machines and Technology
like in Brazil you couldn't buy the cars
you could get here you couldn't get the
guns that you wanted you couldn't get
Electronics because they had closed
borders but other countries because they
you know what I mean they were they had
they were protecting their own
monopolies
uh it's open now but it's like 200
import tax on anything foreign
course all the Brazilian oligarchs
[__] steal all the money Brazil is
extremely corrupt
but guess what the United States is
extremely corrupt too they just do it in
a different way they can get away with
it yeah all these countries are corrupt
well I mean that's it's been that way
since the beginning humans are just
[__] corrupt yeah yeah I mean not
obviously but most humans don't suck
it's just powerful humans it's just yeah
because to get to that level of power
and influencing you got us up you had to
do a bunch of [__] bad [__] so you've
been selected for being an [__]
to get up there a good person couldn't
survive and do the [__] that they're
doing
they just [__] people over they [__]
over all their competition to get there
all right so it's getting very late okay
I have to get up very early in the
morning so we finished this one yeah and
I'm actually really glad that I got
through all of the stories because I
didn't think I was going to be able to
but I wanted to do these five because
they were like really interesting but
yeah so I mean yeah we were talking
about Richie Edwards but I kind of my
theory is I think that he probably I
don't think he
jumped off the bridge right away
I think he was planning to but then he
decided to like hang out for a little
while but then I think he actually did
and I think the only reason they didn't
find him was because he got swept out to
sea probably so I don't think they'll
probably as soon as the bodies in a
drink in a large in a large body of
water it gets very hard to [__] find
that body and it's eaten pretty quickly
yeah it goes out to sea it's eaten real
quickly and it'd be hard to find anyway
and the thing about it it's like I I
think this story like um this particular
even though I'm not like a huge fan of
the Manic Street Preachers like I don't
know a lot about them but I think that
this one resonated with me a lot because
a lot of the locations were talking
about like the Newport bus station I've
been there like lots of times the Severn
bridge that he supposedly jumped off of
I've driven over that like a bunch of
times and it's just like so in Blackwood
I've been there so it's just kind of
like weird that like all these locations
and I can picture them in my mind
because I've actually been there and
that's where they're from you know so I
thought that was like pretty weird
um but yeah so I guess we better wrap it
up because I have to go to sleep
beautiful Jenny you guys need you guys
can't really see it but Jenny is looking
so [__] good man she's getting into
shape working out
yeah
you probably lost 25 pounds at least
yeah I think I think it's about a shape
I think it's about 25 pounds at this
point I'm I'm gunning to lose about
15 more yeah and that's probably that's
about what my goal is but I don't really
want to lose any more than that but I
mean and if I don't it's like not that
big a deal but I mean that's kind of
what my goal is like 15 more pounds and
then I'll be happy yeah but we'll see
um but yeah so I guess we'll wrap it up
so hopefully you guys can uh join us
again on Friday night for our Sidetrack
show because that's always fun where we
just drink and talk about whatever
[__] pops into our heads or whatever
[__] pops into your head
yeah that's what we usually end up
talking about
hookers because we because we might we
might stream tomorrow and I don't we
might do stream eight tomorrow night
yeah but we haven't done it in a few
days because Tom's been sick yeah and
I've been kind of sick but you know we
haven't really been feeling that good so
we haven't been doing it for the last
few days but you know Jamie put in her
two weeks notice she's only got maybe a
week and a few days left I got the rest
of this week and next week and then I
can then I'm free
yeah but then we'll have to like hit
streamate real hard so we can so I can
like make some money you know what I
mean
but I'm happy I'm happy about it I'm
happy I won't have to like drive over
there anymore I'm just kind of hoping
I'm crossing my fingers that like
nothing bad happens to the car in this
last
week and a half like you know what I
mean
like because that would be just my
[__] luck you know what I mean that
it's like I put in my notice and I'm all
excited about starting the new thing and
then all of a sudden like something bad
happens so I'm just kind of like hoping
that doesn't happen I'm not I'm trying
not to jinx jinx myself you know what I
mean but yeah so like I said we'll be
around again on Friday night for our
Sidetrack show so hopefully you guys can
join us for that hopefully you guys
enjoyed this show at least mostly kind
of stayed on topic most of the time I'm
kind of proud of us uh but yeah so have
a good rest of the night you guys and
have a good day tomorrow and we'll see
you guys again on Friday night good